COVERT NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS THE
SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS. TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE
ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE IN THE CAPITAL-
WITH MEMBERS ABLE TO PARTICIPATE
REMOTELY ALTHOUGH TODAY NO ONE
WILL BE PARTICIPATING REMOTELY.
THE MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE
ARE HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM
THOSE PROVIDING TESTIMONY BEFORE
THE COMMITTEE TODAY ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY FOR OUR
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE
YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS
WILL GREATLY AID IN THE LEMONADE
IN ANY ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK I
ANSWERED EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO
BE RECOGNIZE THAT YOU MAY USE
THAT RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE IN
THE PROGRAM. EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO UN MUTE PLEASE
SELECT THE NEW BEFORE YOU BEING
BEGIN SPEAKING. OUR I. T.
PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU BACK ON
MUTE WHEN YOU ARE DONE. ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME AND THEN
YOU ARE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO THE HEARING
ROOM. TO THE EXTENT THE
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW I
WILL BE USING A TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE. FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR
ALL INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT. THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER AND
ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW. EIGHT FOUR FOUR
TWO NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR.
AND THE ACCESS CODE IS. THREE
FIVE THREE ONE TWO EIGHT THREE.
FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE AND
OR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WILL
BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO
DIAL ONE THEN ZERO. PRESS THIS
ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY
FOR AN OPERATOR TO ANSWER YOU TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER THIS
CAN BE A SHORT WAIT. ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU
WILL WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATED CALL YOUR LINE NUMBER.
AT THAT TIME YOU WILL BE ON
MUTED AND YOU ARE NOW READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU MUST MUTE
THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING IN
THE HEARING. ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY AND ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
IS DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETINGS
SERVICE. OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED- GOOD MORNING
TO MY COLLEAGUES HERE ON THE
COMMITTEE. BEFORE WE BEGIN LET'S
ESTABLISH OF QUORUM. A DOCTOR
BACK BILL PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR DORADO HERE. BETTER
GROWTH SENATOR COURT SENATOR
CORTEZ IN SENATOR NEWMAN HERE.
THANK YOU A QUORUM HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED THE SUBCOMMITTEE
FIVE HEARING WILL COVER THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH THE CALIFORNIA
VICTIM COMPENSATION BOARD THE
COMMISSION ON PEACE OFFICER
STANDARDS AND TRAINING AND THE
OFFICE OF THE STATE PUBLIC
DEFENDER WE WILL FIRST HEAR FROM
THE ADMINISTRATION ON THEIR
PROPOSALS AND THEN WE WILL TAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT. ALL ISSUES WILL
BE HELD OPEN AND THERE WILL BE
NO VOTES TAKEN TODAY. OKAY READY
TO ROLL. THE FIRST ISSUE IS
ISSUE ONE IS A CIVIL ASSESSMENT
REDUCTION AND I BELIEVE FINANCE
WILL BE PRESENTING. HI GOOD
MORNING- MARC MINISTER ON THE
FINANCE SO IN CONTINUATION ON IN
CONTINUATION OF THIS
ADMINISTRATION'S EFFORTS. TO
PROVIDE FINANCIAL RELIEF FOR
INDIVIDUALS- FROM THE POSITION
OF FINES AND FEES WITHOUT BUDGET
INCLUDES STATUTORY CHANGES TO
REDUCE OF LOS ASSESSMENT THE SPY
HOUSE FROM THE MAXIMUM OF THREE
HUNDRED TO. ONE HUNDRED FIFTY
DOLLARS- THE CIVIL ASSESSMENTS
IT'S A TOOL USED BY THE STATE
AND COURTS TO HOLD INDIVIDUALS
ACCOUNTABLE WHEN THEY FAIL TO
APPEAR ON THE COURT PROCEEDINGS
ARE PAY A FINE BOB WE RECOGNIZE
THE CURRENCY IS TOO HIGH AND CAN
BE REDUCED TO HELP ALL
CALIFORNIANS. ON THE BUDGET ALSO
INCLUDES THREE MILLION ONGOING
GENERAL FUND TO BACK FILL THE
RESULTING LOSS IN SIMPLE STEPS
AND REVENUES FOR TRUCK WORKS. ON
LAST WEEK LASTLY WE- WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THIS PROPOSAL
TO REDUCE THE BALL SUSSMAN
BUILDS UPON FINDING IT REFORM
EFFORTS TAKEN BY TAKEN BY THE
ADMINISTRATION- INCLUDING THE
ELIMINATION OF VARIOUS
ADMINISTRATIVE FEES FOR CRIMINAL
OFFENSES ALL OF THE EXPANSION OF
THE ABILITY TO PAY PROGRAM THAT
ALLOW LOW INCOME INDIVIDUALS TO
REDUCE FINES AND FEES FROM
TRAFFIC AND NON TRAFFIC
INFRACTIONS ACCORDING TO THEIR
ABILITY TO PAY. HAPPY. TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
VALUE OFFICE. ANY WITH THE LEAD
ANALYST'S WE HAVE CONCERN
AGAINST THANK YOU. OKAY I HAVE A
COUPLE OF A FEW QUICK AND THEN
I'LL OPEN UP TO OUR COLLEAGUES
HERE- JUST TO GET SOME
BACKGROUND AS TO HOW THE
ADMINISTRATION CAME TO SETTLE ON
THE REDUCTION OF A HUNDRED FIFTY
DOLLARS ARE VERSUS OTHER
REDUCTIONS OR ELIMINATION
ALTOGETHER. SO- HI AGAIN MARTIN
IS A PERMANENT FINANCED- SO
WOULD BE- ADMINISTRATION
CONSIDER DIFFERENT ALTERNATIVES
WHEN IT COMES TO THE PRODUCTION
OF THE CYSTS CIVIL ASSESSMENT
HOWEVER WE FEEL THAT. THE
PERCENT REDUCTION STRIKES A
BALANCE OF PROVIDING MEDIA
FISCAL RELIEF FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS AND ALSO PRESERVING
THE VIABILITY OF THE SURPLUS AND
BEING USED AS A TOOL TO KEEP
INDIVIDUALS ACCOUNTABLE TO
COMPEL INDIVIDUALS. APPEAR IN
COURT PROCEEDINGS AND ENGAGE
THEIR FINES I'M JUST NOT THAT
ANY FURTHER EXPANSION OF COURSE
WILL WORK BY YOUR- ADDITIONAL
GENERAL FUND BACKED BILLS SO- WE
SETTLED ON. THE PERCENT. ACCESS
CONSISTENT WITH. THAT WE
SUBMITTED LAST YEAR AS WELL TO
REDUCE SYSTEM BY PERCENT. I KNOW
WE HAVE A TAKEN UP IN THE PAST-
UN NOT ONLY A PROSPECT BUT- OF-
THAT- DID YOU LOOK AT THAT
CONCERT THAT- DID OWED. AND
ALSO- WHAT OTHER- WAYS HAVE YOU
THOUGHT OF AS FAR AS- YOU KNOW
HELPING PEOPLE YOU KNOW. IT'S
GETTING PEOPLE OF THEM. YOU KNOW
FEELING THE COMPELLED TO APPEAR-
BUT NOT SOMETHING THAT WOULD BE
SO BURDENSOME TO ESPECIALLY POOR
PEOPLE. I'M SURE SO- B. AS- A
THAT AS YOU'RE AWARE ON THE
CIVIL SYSTEM DOESN'T YOU BUT AS
A TOOL TO COMPEL INDIVIDUALS- TO
A APPEAR IN COURT- YOU KNOW HI.
THIS IS CERTAINLY AN ALTERNATIVE
TO ON BENCH WARRANTS WHICH IS A
POLICY THAT ADDED MINISTRATION
BUTTON- WHAT I WANT- THE COURTS
TO- TO TAKE IF WE WERE TO
ELIMINATE THE AND- I SIMPLE
ASSESSMENT SO- WE DETERMINED
THAT- THE SIMPLE ASSESSMENT.
WOULD CERTAINLY BE A VIABLE TOOL
TO KEEP INDIVIDUALS ACCOUNTABLE-
WHILE PREVENTING AND THE POLICY-
TO ISSUE BENCH WARRANTS TO
COMPEL INDIVIDUALS- BUT ALSO
REDUCE TACTIC IMPACT THEM- YOU
KNOW- THE- FIVE. REDUCING THE
FEES BUT THEN SO YOU KNOW MAKING
SURE THAT THERE IS A THEM TO OF
THE TWO- OKAY WELL I DEFINITELY
A PRE THAT WERE ADDRESSING THIS
AND BE SHE TO F. ON WILL KEEP ON
WITH THE CONVERSATION COLLEAGUES
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS CENTER
CRITICIZING. SO THANK YOU
MEASURE- JUST LISTENING HAVE A
COUPLE QUESTIONS IT'S HUNDRED
COMMON I'M I'M NOT SURE THAT-
THE JUXTAPOSITION OF A BENCH
WARRANTS VERSUS A SIMPLE
ASSESSMENT FEES IS REALLY
APPROPRIATE BECAUSE OF THE FACT
MATTER IS WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE RATIONALE HERE TO. THE
HELP LOW INCOME CALIFORNIA'S
PARTICULARLY PEOPLE OF COLOR IF
THEY DON'T HAVE THE MONEY- I
THINK THAT'S WHERE THE LOW
INCOME PIECE OF THIS IS COMING
FROM THAT HOUSE AT ANY
INCENTIVE. TO COME IN YOU EITHER
HAVE IT OR YOU DON'T I MEAN
THERE'S ALWAYS AN ARGUMENT NOT
THAT I'M PRO BENCH WARRANTS BUT
THERE'S A REASON ARGUMENT THAT-
YOU KNOW BECOMING WITHOUT THE
CIVIL ASSESSMENT FEE BECAUSE
YOU'RE MANDATED TO COME IN-
YOU'RE BETTER OFF ECONOMICALLY
INTO SOMEBODY ALREADY YOU CAN
STILL BUY GROCERIES OR YOU ARE
TAKING MONEY OUT OF POCKET
YOU'RE FAMILY AND YOU'RE NOT.
HAVING SOMEBODY COME AFTER YOU
FOR COLLECTIONS LATER ON SO
AGAINST THE REAL QUESTION I HAVE
IS OR THE- PERSONALS A PROGRAM
EFFECTIVE AT ALL PRESUMABLY. THE
EFFECTIVENESS IS LIMITED IN THE
EQUITY OF IT ALL IS LIMITED
OTHERWISE WE WOULDN'T BE
REDUCING- THE FI HERO IN HALF IN
THE FIRST PLACE. BUT THEN. IT'S
ME BY SLIDING THE FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS OVER. TO ESSENTIALLY
GENERAL FUND SUBSIDY OF THE
COURTS- IT JUST STRIKES ME THAT
IT'S AT SOME POINT WE JUST NEED
TO RESTRUCTURE HOW WE'RE DOING
THIS COMPLETELY- IT'S JUST KIND
OF ROBBING PETER TO PAY PAUL AT
THIS POINT- I'D LIKE THE TO THE
WHAT I WOULD CALL THE TEMPORARY
OUTCOME OF REDUCED FEES. BUT
MAYBE WE OUGHT TO BE SORT OF
RIPPING THE BAND AID OFF HERE
AND JUST SAYING THAT THE FEES
ARE- NOT HELPFUL WE NEED TO
ELIMINATE THEM IN IN HEALTH. YOU
KNOW JUST TO PUT UP A POLICY
DECISION TO BE REDUCING THEM IN
SUCH AS DEALING WITH THIS IS A
ONE OFF THIS YEAR BUT HAVING A
FIVE YEAR PLAN FOR EXAMPLE TO
JUST PLEASE AMOUNTS- THOSE
REPORTS THAT I TELL OF. THEM HAD
WAITED. MMHM WE ALREADY HEARD
ABOUT. THANK YOU SEE
MINISTRATIONS OF RESIDUAL
COUNCIL'S POINT OF VIEW ON BENCH
WARRANTS VERSUS FEES BUT- IT IS
OR HASN'T BEEN THOUGHT ABOUT.
MORE THOUGHT THERE ABOUT WHAT
THE FEES ARE WOULD LOOK LIKE ON
THIS REVIEW SAID IS THAT THE
OVERALL IDEA OF. I DID THE-
OVERALL IDEAS NECESSARILY
TENTATIVELY SET UP THIS TIME- IT
SO IT'S THE CERTAINLY MINISTRY
BUT CONDITION BURKE BEST STUFF
AND AS A TOOL TO A. I A TOOL TO
COMPEL AND TO APPEAR COURT- I AM
. CERTAIN THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE
OUR SUBMITTED- CAN BE A
GOVERNOR'S- I ALSO WANTED THAT
WE ARE- IN THE PRE FISCAL YEAR-
X. EXPAND B. AND- ABILITY TO PAY
PER- TO ASSIST LOW INCOME
INDIVIDUALS- TO. DRAW DOWN OR TO
REDUCE THEIR OTHER NAY. OR I'M-
FINANCING FEES THAT THEY MIGHT
BE FACING ACCORDING TO THEIR
ABILITY TO PAY SO THAT'S
CERTAINLY PART OF. YOU KNOW PART
OF OVERALL I BY THE POLICY EVERY
BEEN CA- IN ADDITION TO THAT THE
REDUCTION OF THE SIMPLE STUFF
THAT. FIVE I HAD I DID NOT SEE
THAT IF IT'S HERE IN THE PACKET
COMMITTEE MADE A- DECISION ON
THAT WITH REGARD TO THE ABILITY
TO PAY PROGRAM THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE- HAVE ALREADY- THAT WAS
INCLUDED IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
BUDGET- IT'S THAT THAT'S ALREADY
IN. IT IN STATUTE. IF WE CAN GET
THAT INFORMATION- BETWEEN NOW
AND WHEN WE PICTURE COULD NOT BE
HELPFUL JUST AS- ADDITIONAL
CONTEXT BECAUSE- FOR ME WHEN I
WHEN I SAY WE I. AND I'M ASKING
ON THE OF THE COMMITTEE MANAGER
THAT'S OF. BUT THE- THE EV'S IN
THE I HAVE- JUST NOW. IN IN
EXCHANGE FOR GIVE RID OF WHICH
IS- ALSO WE HELPING WITH THIS OF
WHICH IS YOU KNOW PUTTING THIS
IN HALF ACROSS THE BOARD IS IT
JUST LOW INCOME PERSONS OF COLOR
WE HELPING. YOU KNOW A BUNCH OF
FOLKS WHO COULD AFFORD TO PAY
THE FEES- AND I THINK YOU TO
START OF THE ANSWER THAT
QUESTION I DON'T NEED YOU TO.
VERBALIZE ANYMORE BUT IF YOU
COULD GIVE US AS A REFRESHER
LAST YEAR'S OF- EAT. ADOPTION
THAT THAT WOULD BE THAT WOULD BE
HELPFUL TO ME FROM. JUST BY THE
MANAGER WITH BUILT I'D LIKE TO
DISCUSS FLAG THIS. FOR NO OTHER
REASON THAT I THINK FROM A
POLICY STANDPOINT AS WE GET
TOWARD THE END OF THE BUDGET
PROCESS I DO THINK
LEGISLATIVELY- WE COULD IF
THAT'S OUR- DISPOSITION- YOU
KNOW TALK ABOUT UP SOME KIND OF
A FULL PHASE OUT OVER TIME. IS
HAVE THAT DISCUSS OF THE TO AND
- SORT OF TAKE THE TEMPERATURE
OF HOW PEOPLE REALLY FEEL ABOUT
THESE FEES EXISTING AT ALL I
KNOW. IN MY OWN COUNTY A FEW
YEARS AGO WE COMPLETELY
ELIMINATED THEM- FOR CERTAIN AGE
GROUPS AND CATEGORIES OF PEOPLE.
THAT BECAUSE IT JUST WASN'T
WORKING- SERVICE SO I JUST I
THINK THERE'S A POLICY QUESTION
COMPETITORS TO WHERE WE WANT TO
KEEP GOING WITH IT YEP. THAT'S
ALL THANK YOU VERY MUCH SO WITH
REGARDS TO THE FURTHER
INFORMATION. YEAH THAT WAS ON I
WAS ON THE FURTHER INFORMATION
ON WHICH IS ASKING FOR- ALWAYS
EMBARRASSING TO SAY THIS I GUESS
BUT I WAS JUST ASKING FOR- FOR
THIS. TO BE SUBMITTED TO US WHAT
WE ADOPTED LAST YEAR IN TERMS OF
THE ABILITY TO PAY. PROGRAM AT.
IF WE DEAL WITH SO MANY THINGS I
JUST DON'T REMEMBER EXACTLY HOW
THE STRUCTURE NEXT TO BE HELPFUL
. TO HAVE THE IN HAND AS WE GO
FORWARD. OKAY THANK YOU FOR
BERMAN THERE BRIEFLY AND THEN
YOU KNOW JUST LIKE I AGREE
SENATE QUOTATION OF BUILDING A
POINT YOU MADE TO EACH YOUR THE
CALL PROPORTIONATE IS AN
IMPORTANT PRINCIPLE WE SHOULD
FIGURE OUT HOW TO BETTER APPLY
THAT. BUT I THINK IT'S ALSO TRUE
THAT DID THAT WE SHOULDN'T WE
SHOULD BE CAREFUL THAT WE'RE NOT
FUNDING THE JUDGES THE JUSTICE
SYSTEM THREE CITATIONS RIGHT NOT
THE PHRASE I'VE HEARD. TAXATION
BY STATE CITATION. BECAUSE TO
THE EXTENT THAT THE SYSTEM
RELIES ON FINE SHE CREATES
PERVERSE INCENTIVES. AT A
MINIMUM NOT TO LOOK AT- TRIPS
YOU KNOW THE POSSIBILITY OF
FUNDAMENTAL CHANGES. AND SO
THERE'S A NOTE IN OUR ANALYSIS
HERE THAT THAT SAYS ACCORDING TO
A SURVEY OF THE DEBT FREE.
JUSTICE CALIFORNIA COALITION 73%
OF CALIFORNIA'S WITH TRAFFIC
INFRACTIONS DID NOT EVEN KNOW
THERE WAS A FEAT FOR MISSING A
DEADLINE. TO PAY APPEARED
CORDIAL. YOU KNOW I WOULD ARGUE
THAT'S PROBABLY NOT THEIR FAULT
THAT'S OUR FAULT- AND TO THE
EXTENT WE DON'T. TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THAT AND IT
ALSO NOTES THAT. THE USE OF KIND
OF NEW TECHNOLOGIES LIKE TEXT
REMINDERS AN OPERATOR ALSO
SUCCESSFUL AYE I WOULD POINT OUT
THESE TWO THINGS ARE MUTUALLY
EXCLUSIVE. JAMES COMEY YOU COULD
POINT OUT TO PEOPLE VIA TEXT
MESSAGE THAT YOU MIGHT WANT TO
TAKE YOUR FINER THIS THE
CONSEQUENCES BECOMES. MORE
SEVERE- BUT AGAIN I MEAN I THINK
AT SOME POINT WE HAVE TO REALLY
LOOK HARD AT PROPORTIONALITY-
BECAUSE THE LARGER GOALS REMAIN
WHICH IS WHERE TO CREATE
DISINCENTIVES- TO DO. NOT DOING
CERTAIN THINGS APPROPRIATE
PENALTIES FOR DOING THOSE
THINGS. THAT YOU KNOW IT'S RIGHT
I'D BE INTERESTED I GUESS IS
THAT THAT'S A POLICY MATTER NOT
A BUDGET MATTER. TO A LEAVE IT
FOR NOW. OKAY THANK YOU SIR AND-
BUT I. WHAT WE- YOU'RE- MISTER
HUMAN. IS SON- MISLI. IS THAT WE
- WON ONE LITTLE BIT MORE
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH. TO THIS
ISSUE. AND NOT. A SYSTEM THAT
RELIES ON IN. GREAT PART ON POOR
PEOPLE. TO PAY FOR- SO IT WOULD
BE GOOD TO GET THE INFORMATION
THAT WAS REQUESTED BY SENATOR
CORTEZ THE- BUT ALSO. GIVE A
LITTLE BIT MORE COMPREHENSIVE
APPROACH RATHER THAN. LET'S TRY
THIS ONE YEAR AND- AND WE
ALREADY KNOW WHAT THE ALT SOME
ALTERNATIVES ARE. AND LET'S BE
MORE COMPREHENSIVE. THANK YOU
ANY MORE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
NO OKAY WE MOVE ONE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR MENACE- MOVE ON TO
. THE NEXTIS ISSUED TO TRIAL
COURT OF FUNDING ON THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL WILL PRESENT. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME IS
JOHN WORK LAW I'M THE CHIEF
ADMINISTRATIVE OFFICER YOU'RE
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL I'D LIKE TO
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS YOU TODAY ON THIS
IMPORTANT. PROPOSAL FROM THE
GOVERNOR OF THE CHIEF JUSTICE
FOR COUNSEL AND THE COURT TURNED
STRONG SUPPORTER OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET WE
ARE GRATEFUL TO THE GOVERNOR FOR
RECOGNIZING OUR LONG STANDING
STRUCTURAL FUNDING GAPS AND-
HOUSE PROPOSED WOULD GO A LONG
WAY TO HELPING OUT THE COURTS.
FIRST ISSUE IS OUR FOR- THAT
WOULD BE A HUNDRED BILLION
DOLLARS ON GOING. FOR THE
PURPOSE OF- CREATING EQUITY
AMONGST THE COURTS AS YOU KNOW
THE COURTS HAVE LONG STRUGGLED-
FINANCIALLY WITH RUNNING THEIR
COURTS AND ON THIS MONEY WOULD
DO. A GREAT DEAL TO HELP THE
COURTS TO STABILIZE SERVICE
HOURS AND DAYS COURTS ARE OPEN
TO THE PUBLIC- WHEN IMPROVE
EMPLOYEE RETENTION RATES FIRE-
RESTORING AND INCREASING
STAFFING LEVELS. I WOULD IMPROVE
SERVICE DELIVERY- BY REDUCING
WEIGHT AND CASE PROCESSING THE
WASTE. WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
COURTS THAT ARE. OUR LOWER
FINDING CORKS- DAD'S ARE LUIS
FUND COURT AT 73% OF ALL THE
WORKLOAD AND- AS YOU KNOW MANY
OF OUR LARGER COURTS LA FOR
EXAMPLE IS OUR OUR OUR LARGEST
COURT IN THE STATE IN THE NATION
THAT MATTER YEAH IS IT SITTING
AT JUST. BELOW 75% FUNDING FOR
WORKLOADS ORANGE COUNTY IS THAT
78% SAMPOERNA DINO SEVENTY SIX
PERCENT. AND TULARE- ONE OR
SMALLER COURTS SEVENTY SIX
PERCENT- ALL IN GREAT NEED
YELLOW IS OUR OUR OUR LOWEST
FUNDING COURT ACT. 73% FIRST
AVERAGE IS ALL RIGHT AROUND 80%
BOB BROUGHT AND SO THIS ARE.
MONEY WOULD GREAT OUT HELP THE
COURT. OUR INTENT I THINK YOU'RE
SO WERE THAT THESE DOLLARS TO GO
TO THE FUNDING COURTS ON YOUR
AGENDA MATT CHAIR. WE ASK HOW
WITH BE ALEX OUT- I'D LIKE TO
YOUR TO BACK IN JULY OF. TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY ONE WHEN THE
COUNCIL APPROVED THE BUDGET
PROPOSAL MOVES FORWARD TO-
STRETCHING FOR CONSIDERATION- IT
ASK FOR EQUITY FUNDING AND YET-
THE MASS IN WHICH WE WOULD
ALLOCATE THOSE FUNDS WOULD BE TO
THOSE COURTS AT THE LOWEST.
FUNDING LEVEL STATEWIDE SO THAT
SO THAT'S HOW THAT WOULD GO OUT
OF THE NEXT ISSUE ON IN YOUR
AGENDA MADAM CHAIR IS OUR
REQUEST FOR CONSUMER PRICE
ADJUSTMENT. THAT WOULD INCLUDE
EIGHTY FOUR POINT TWO MILLION
ONGOING AND RECOGNIZED- THE
SECOND STRUCTURAL ISSUE WHICH IS
ONGOING NEED FOR ADJUSTMENT IN
OUR COST PRESSURES DUE TO
INFLATION. BOB THE NEXT ISSUE
ADDRESSES ARE JUDGESHIPS BOB
THIS WOULD INCLUDE TWENTY THREE.
FUNDING FOR THE REMAINING TWENTY
THREE JUDGE SHIPS THAT WERE
ORIGINALLY APPROVED BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN YEAH AB ONE FIFTY
NINE. AND SO THAT WOULD. BE MUCH
NEEDED BY JUDGES SPOTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND THEN
FINALLY- ADDRESSES ARE REVENUE
BACK STILL NEEDS AS WE HAVE.
CIVIL THREE AND FIND OUR REVENUE
HAS BEEN INCREASING OVER THE
YEARS IT WOULD CONTINUE I
GENERAL FUND SUPPORT. OF THOSE.
I MEAN GAPS. I AM MADAM BY-
COURT LEADERSHIP WE- J. ZANER
RAPPERS. OF THE TRIAL PRESIDE
JUDGE AT FIVE CAN- AS WELL AS
PRISON JUDGE OF SANTA CLARA WE
HAVE KEVIN HARRIGAN COURT
EXECUTIVE OFFICER FOR THE TAMA
SUPERIOR COURT AND CHAIR OF OUR
COURT EXECUTIVE ADVISORY
COMMITTEE. WE HAVE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL STAFF BOB ROB- YOUNG.
HE'S OUR CHIEF OPERATING OFFICER
AS WELL AS LOCKER. THEODORE RICH
AVAILABLE HELLO AS OUR BUDGET
EXPERT SHOULD CALLING YOU MADAM
CHAIR OR MEMBERS. HAVE QUESTIONS
FOR US. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER WARDLAW- WE WILL HAVE NOT
MOVE ON FINANCE TO GET THE
COMMENTS IN THEN WE MAY GO BACK
FOR QUESTIONS THANK YOU. HI I'M
ARGUMENT IS A PERMANENT FINANCE-
JUST WANTED TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
. RECOMMENDATION AND TARGET THE
FUNDING TOWARDS LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITIES- AS LAID OUT IN THE
AGENDA- WE JUST KNOW THAT THE
FISCAL EQUITY FUNDING MAY BE
USED- BY TRIAL COURTS TO ADDRESS
BACKLOGS DELAYS FOR COURT USERS
OR ADDRESSING PHYSICAL. THING
FOR CORPORATIONS AND FURTHERMORE
THE ADMINISTRATION BELIEVES IT
IS CRITICAL TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL BRANCH FLEXIBILITY
WITH HOW THIS RESOURCES ARE
ALLOCATED AND WHAT THESE
RESOURCE RESOURCES CAN BE USED
FOR BECAUSE THE JUDICIAL BRANCH
AS A SEPARATE BRANCH OF
GOVERNMENT SHOULD HAVE
DISCRETION ON HOW THESE.
RESOURCES ARE ALLOCATED IN EACH
PORT HAS DIFFERENT NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED WITH RESPONDING- I
CONCLUDE MY COMMENTS THANK YOU.
THANK. YOU VERY MUCH MISLI.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND ANY
WHAT THE LEGISLATURE OFFICE ON
SO AS IN. BY VOTERS RIGHT OF THE
OF FINANCE. WE DO HAVE COMMENTS
FOR YOU SPECIFICALLY RELATED TO
THE ONE HUNDRED MILLION TO
PROMOTE FISCAL EQUITY-
SPECIFICALLY WE DO RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE INSURE THAT THE
AMOUNT OF FUNDING PROVIDED AS
WELL AS HOW IT'S ALLOCATED SH
REFLECTS LEGISLATIVE PRIORITIES.
SEVEN PROMOTING FISCAL EQUITY IS
A IS A POLL WITH MERIT- AS IT
PROMOTES EQUAL ACCESS TO JUSTICE
ACROSS THE STATE. HOWEVER AT
THIS POINT- IT'S CURRENTLY
UNCLEAR EXACTLY HOW THE MONEY
WOULD BE DISTRIBUTED AT THAT
DECISION AS MUCH ADDITIONAL
COUNSEL. WE WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT
THERE ARE DIFFERENT WAYS OF
PROMOTING TRUST FISCAL EQUITY
WHICH CAN IMPACT OF THE NUMBER
OF COURTS THAT RECEIVE FUNDING
AS WELL AS HOW MUCH FUNDING A
RECEIPT. SO GO BACK TO MISTER
MOORE LOTS COMMENTS FOR EXAMPLE
YOU KNOW ONE WAY OF DOING THAT
IS TO TARGET THE COURTS THAT ARE
BELOW THE STATEWIDE AVERAGE
WHICH IS THE WAY THAT WE
APPROACH IT IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN. BUT ANOTHER
WAY IS ALSO TO BRING- ALL COURTS
UP TO A MINIMUM. KNESSET LEVEL.
IN ADDITION TO THIS ALSO THAT
THERE ARE OTHER PRIOR THAT COULD
BECOMES. SHE WE ARE. YOU KNOW AT
X. SOME OF THE- WERE TO THE
PANDEMIC'S RELATED TO BACKLOG
AND DELAYS IN COURT PROCEEDINGS
AND SO THAT COULD BE AN AREA
WHERE WE MIGHT WANT. TO MINIMIZE
IMPACTS ON COURT COURT USERS AND
THAT'S ADDRESSING EQUITY IN
DIFFERENT WAY YOU KNOW EQUITY IN
TERMS OF PUBLIC ACCESS AND HOW
QUICKLY EACH CASE CAN BE
RESOLVED. SO IN LINE WITH THIS
ONE OPTION THAT THE LEGISLATURE
COULD CONSIDER IS TO PROVIDE
SOME OR ALL OF THE REQUESTED
FUNDING IN THE BUDGET YEAR. TO
ADDRESS PANDEMIC RELATED IMPACTS
AND TO KIND OF HELP WITH THAT
THE LEGISLATURE COULD ASK THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH TO REPORT IN THE
SPRING. TO BASICALLY IDENTIFY
WHERE THE GREATEST NEEDS ARE AND
THEN AFTER THE BUDGET YEAR THE
FUNDS CAN BE ALLOCATED- YOU KNOW
FOR EXAMPLE TO BRING ALL OF THE
COURTS. TO AT LEAST EIGHTY FOUR
POINT FIVE PERCENT. OF THE NEED
WHICH IS WHAT YOU KNOW A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS POTENTIALLY
COULD BRING THEM YEAH. SO WITH
THAT WE'RE. HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOUNG. THANK YOU
MISLI- COLLEAGUES. DO YOU HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS SENATE
QUARTERS YES. FRIEDMAN SURE-
CUSHION FOR FINANCE ON THE ON
THE- ON THE THREE POINT 8% THE
INFLATIONARY ADJUSTMENT
PHYSICIST PARTIBLE- LARGER-
PLANNED FOR INFLATIONARY
ADJUSTMENTS ACROSS DEPARTMENTS
OBVIOUSLY IN THIS COMMITTEE-
CHIEF JUDICIAL IS JUST IS JUST
ONE AREA OF CONCERN WILL BE
TAKEN UP CITIES CDCR
TRANSPORTATION OTHER THINGS SO
I'M JUST WONDERING IF WE SHOULD
BE EXPECTING. A CONSISTENT THREE
POINT 8% INFLATIONARY ADJUSTMENT
COMING THROUGH THE BUDGET
PROCESS THIS YEAR. OR IS THIS
SOMETHING UNIQUE TO- THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH AT THIS POINT-
HELLO HI MARC BERMAN OF THE
PERMANENT FINANCE AT. THIS
RECALL THAT THREE POINT 8%
ADJUSTMENT IS IT IS REALLY JUST
SPECIFIC TOOK THE INITIAL
COUNSEL ACCOUNT- ED CAN SPIT IT
CERTAINLY NOT PART OF A BROADER
STATEWIDE ADJUSTMENT- I'M NOT TO
SAY THAT THERE THERE THERE CAN'T
BE BUT THIS SPECIFIC PROPOSAL IS
SPECIFICALLY FOR THE REPORTS.
AMONG BIT CAN ABOUT- TO CENTER
INTER AGENCY EQUITY IF YOU WILL
FOR A BETTER WAY TO PUT A PIC
MAYBE CURTI IS A BETTER WORD- IT
AND ALSO KIND OF A ME TOO
ATTITUDE I DON'T KNOW WHY IF
IT'S IF IT'S TRULY AN
INFLATIONARY ADJUSTMENT-
NOBODY'S FAULT OTHER THAN THE
FACT THAT WE HAVE INFLATION IN A
THREE POINT 8% IS AN ACCURATE
NUMBER. WHY WOULDN'T THAT APPLY
TO THE COST OF BREAD FOR A
PRISON INMATES SOME- HERE
TRANSPORTATION PROJECT COSTS AND
ALL KINDS OF OTHER THINGS SO.
I'M I DON'T KNOW IF THE ILLEGAL
HAS A COMMENT ON THAT BUT IF IT
WAS THAT RAISED AT ALL IN THE
ALEJO'S OFFICE SAID. BUT PERHAPS
THERE SHOULD BE SOME CONCERN
ABOUT THE PRESIDENT OF A UNIQUE
INFLATIONARY ADJUSTMENT FOR ONE
PARTICULAR- PIECE OF THE BUDGET
. THE OVERALL BUDGET. SO ARE
UNDER ISSUE ON THIS ISSUE- THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH IS A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT FROM SOME OF THE OTHER
DEPARTMENTS SO WHEN YOU CONSIDER
DEPARTMENTS LIKE CITY C. R. THE
LEGISLATURE DOES APPROVED- AND
WILL USE AGREEMENTS RELATED TO
SALARIES- AND THEIR OTHER
DISCUSSIONS RELATED TO THAT TO
THEIR BUDGET. ON THE COURT SIDE-
WHILE THERE WAS A TRIAL COURT
REALIGNMENT- SHIFTING
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE COURTS TO
THE STATE- COURT EMPLOYEES OR
COURT EMPLOYEES THERE AND
THEY'RE NOT- WE DON'T THAT THE
LEGISLATURE DOES NOT APPROVE
ADULT ADULT USE IN THE SAME WAY
AND SO- AS PART OF THE BUDGET
SOMETIMES BUT DEPARTMENT FINANCE
WILL PROVIDE AN UNALLOCATED
AUGMENTATION- AND THEN SOMETIMES
LIKE IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET THEY
WILL PROVIDE A SPECIFIC
PERCENTAGE AMOUNTS AND SO THAT'S
WHAT YOU SEE BEFORE YOU I DON'T
KNOW IF THAT PROVIDE HELPFUL
CONTEXT. WILL IT IT DOES IT
RAISES THE QUESTION ARE YOU
SAYING THAT THESE
DISINFLATIONARY JUST MINUTES FOR
PERSONNEL COSTS. A PAYROLL
BENEFITS- PERS OR I DON'T
UNDERSTAND I YOU EXAM OF YOU
KNOW THE CALL OF A LOAF OF BREAD
FOR PRISON INMATES I KNOW A
CAN'T KEEP TRACK OF EVERYTHING
BUT I MY OWN COUNTY- THE NEWS
TWO DAYS AGO WAS SAID THE BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS HAS TO COME UP
WITH A MILLION AND A HALF
DOLLARS FOR INFLATIONARY
ADJUSTMENT. FOR THE JAIL SYSTEM
THERE- BIG COUNTY BIG JAIL
SYSTEM- SO OBVIOUSLY THERE IS
INFLATIONARY PRESSURES. BEYOND
JUST. PERSONNEL I TOTALLY
UNDERSTAND ABOUT REALIGNMENT IT
FORTUNATELY OR UNFORTUNATELY
HAVE BEEN IN OFFICE LONG ENOUGH
TO HAVE LIVED THROUGH THAT
MYSELF BUT- I GUESS I WAS JUST
ASKING THE QUESTION OF IT IS A
THREE POINT 8% BASED ON SOME
INDEX THAT WE SHOULD BE
EXPECTING OTHER FOLKS. TO BE TO
BE USING OR OR LOOKING AT IN
TERMS OF THE COST OF CARE OF ITS
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING RELATED OR
NOT IT'S IT SEEMS TO ME OR MO
YOU RELATED THAT. YOU'RE
ESTABLISHING. RIGHT HERE AT THE
FOR END OF THIS BUDGET PROCESS
IN THIS COMMITTEE- THREE POINT
8% SENSUALLY APPROACH
INFORMATION ORIGINAL SPENT. MAKE
A KNOWLEDGE THAT THREE POINT
EIGHT- SOME COMMENT ON THAT
THREE POINT EIGHT- IT WAS YEAH
IT WAS DETERMINED BY. THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AT THE
TIME BUT OF COURSE THAT YOU
KNOW- THE RATES HE'S ASKED THAT
WAS JUST AN ESTIMATE AT THAT
TIME AND- RATE CERTAINLY CHANGE
AS MORE DATA INSTANCE THAT. IS
SINCE THE CHOIR- AND WITH
REGARDS TO THE TO BE- HOW THE
FUNDS. ARE USED- THE- P. THREE
EIGHT- AMOUNT. IS JUST
OPERATIONS FOR OF COURSE CAN USE
ABSTAINED TO- MAYBE THAT- JUST
COUNCIL CAN PROVIDE EXAMPLES OF
HOW BETTER COURTS HAVE USED TO
STUFF THE PAST. SEVENTY ALL. IF
THERE BEEN A PLEASURE
ADJUSTMENTS RECENTLY IN THE
JITTERS ACCOUNTS WERE ORDERED
ONE OF THE- THE PRESIDING JUDGES
WANTS TO. WAS IT DOES TAKE A
DEEPER DIVE AND TELLS HOW THE
TYPICALLY USE THE MONEY I THINK
MAYBE ONE MINUTE ARE ON THAT I
WANT TO TAKE UP ALL THE
COMMITTEES TIME PURCHASE HEARING
- A TOP LINE OF. WHAT THE MONEY
ISSUES FOR. EIGHT BY THE WAY I'M
HOME I UNDERSTAND WE NEED
INFLATIONARY ADJUSTMENTS RIGHT
NOW I'M NOT FIGHTING THE IDEA OF
AN INFLATION ADJUSTMENT I'M NOT
EVEN FIGHTING THE IDEA OF THE
GOING TO PERSONNEL I'M JUST.
MORE CONCERNED ABOUT. SORT OF A
ME TOO ATTITUDE THROUGHOUT THE
ORGANIZATION OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA MR WARD LINE WOULD
YOU LIKE TO RESPOND. THANK YOU
THANK YOU SENATOR CALL I
APPRECIATE YOUR INTEREST AND- I
WOULD INVITE KEVIN HARRIGAN OUR
CORE EXECUTIVE OFFICER AS WELL
AS- ALEXANDER I WAS TO
SPECIFICALLY HOW COURTS UTILIZE
THESE FINDINGS ARE DIRECTLY IN
THE COURTS. THANK YOU FOR THAT
JOHN AND IT'S A PLEASURE TO BE
WITH THE COMMITTEE THIS MORNING
MY NAME'S KEVIN HARRIGAN
ACCORDING SECOND OF OFFICER TO
HIM COURT AND CURRENT CHAIR OF
THE COURT EXECUTIVES ADVISORY
COMMITTEE AND- BY. THE USE OF
INFLATIONARY MONIES IS KIND OF
AN ALL OF THE ABOVE HI- NEED AND
IT DEPENDS ON EACH COUNTIES NEED
BUT GENERALLY I WOULD GO TO
COST- INCREASES RELATED TO WAGES
OR CONTRACT COSTS- IN JANITORIAL
IS A EXAMPLE AND SO IT WOULD BE
AN ACROSS THE BOARD- OPERATION
AS AS TIME PROGRESSES. SO HAPPY
TO PROVIDE MORE INFORMATION YOU
YOU MENTIONED THAT A QUICK
MINUTE AND SO I'M HAPPY TO ASK
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS BUT
GENERALLY IT'S ALL COST
PRESSURES THAT HAVE TO BE
ACKNOWLEDGED SHORT OF FUNDING
THAT WOULD BE KIND OF CONSIDERED
A- POSSIBLE DECREASE S. AS THAT
WOULD ALL THE WAY AT. THE
FUNDING THAT'S CURRENTLY
AVAILABLE. THANK THANK YOU KNOW
THAT WAS A PERFECT QUICK MINUTE
AND I APPRECIATE IN THE BREEZE A
CONCERN AND- I UNDERSTAND THE
ANSWER- I HAVE ONE OTHER
QUESTION MANAGER AND HAS TO DO
SOMETHING ENTIRELY DIFFERENT. ON
ON THIS. IN THIS SECTION- AND
THEN HAS TO DO WITH- THE BACKLOG
ISSUE- BUT I NOTE IN- IN THE. IN
MY NOTES THAT- MY OWN COUNTY
SANTA CLARA COUNTY- IT HAS A
PLENTY OF AUTHORIZATION FOR THE
JUDICIAL POSITIONS BUT- WHAT
WE'RE HEARING FROM THE COUNTY
AND IT YOU KNOW AGAIN MAYBE
MAYBE CHURCHCENTER WOULD
COMMENT ON THIS GIVEN HIS TIES
TO THAT COUNTY. IS THAT- THERE'S
A BACKLOG THERE OF INMATES
WAITING DISPOSITION THAT IS NOW
AVERAGING ELEVEN MONTHS BUT A
NOT. ENOUGH I GOT THAT
INFORMATION FROM THE C. O. O. OF
THE COUNTY SANTA CLARA- BECAUSE
THEY'RE BEING ASKED TO TRY TO
PROVIDE SOME RELIEF TO THE COURT
SYSTEM THERE- IN. THE WHAT I
WHAT I REALLY WANT TO ASK IS.
THESE DOLLARS THAT ARE INTENDED
TO CLEAR BACKLOG OR THE ARE
THERE ARE THEY BEING BASED ON
OUR WILL BE BASED ON. ON WHERE
THE NEED IS- EIGHT EIGHT. OR IS
HE NOW LET ME JUST ME JUST PUT
RIGHT THERE AND JUST US A QUICK
AND HE QUESTION. RESTORED LOWER
. THANK YOU SENATOR- SO BROADLY
WITH REGARD TO THE BACKLOG
FUNDING AND WE ARE VERY GRATEFUL
FOR- WE WENT THROUGH TO YOU-
DISTRIBUTIONS TO THE COURTS- WE
INITIALLY TOOK DATA- BACKED OUT
LAST MARCH AND THE INFORMED OUR
FIRST ALLOCATION THAT WENT TO
THE COURTS IN OCTOBER THAT WAS
AN INITIAL THIRTY MILLION DOLLAR
ALLOCATION OUT- THE SECOND
ALLOCATION WHEN OUT IN JANUARY
THIS PAST JANUARY AND WAS
INFORMED BY OUR OUR LATEST DATA
POOL- THAT WAS- OF JUNE LAST
YEAR WE ARE. CONTINUALLY
COLLECTING DATA ON WHERE THE
COURTS ARE RELATIVE TO THEIR
BACKLOGS- WELL- FORM- FURTHER
DISCUSSIONS WITH YOU AND THE
ADMINISTRATION ON ADDITIONAL
NEEDS AND AGAIN- THE STRUCTURAL
FUNDING WILL GREATLY ASSIST
THOSE COURTS ALL CORDS- THAT ARE
UNDER- WELL- RIGHT WELL OUR-
COURSE THERE LEAST. IN THE- TO
TACKLE THE BACK- AS WELL AS A-
WIDE FOR. OF OTHER THINGS THE
BACKLOG FUNDS. WERE ON. TO ALL
COURTS THAT. IDENTIFIED A BACK.
I HOPE THAT'S HELPFUL CENTER. IT
IS IT IS CLEAR AS THIS BUT-
WORKING IF I'M WRONG- THE THIRTY
NINE POINT NINE MILLION DOLLARS
IN FOR. THAT'S PROPOSED FOR
THREE ADDITIONAL COURT JUDGE
SEEM TO BE TIED TO TOBACCO I
GUESS WHAT I'M IS. I KNOW COUNTY
MY OWN WE'RE IS NOT THE CHIPSETS
THE PROBLEM- IS ELSE'S IS
CREATING THE BACKLOG PERHAPS
IT'S A COMBINATION OF THINGS-
BUT I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE'S SOMETHING HERE IN THESE
DOLLARS THAT WERE- BEING ASKED
TO SUPPORT OUR PROVEN. IN THE
BUDGET THAT'S GOING TO CLEAR. A
BACKLOG WHATEVER THE CAUSE
NOTCHES JUDGESHIPS- HE AND IT
AND AGAIN I DON'T WANT TO RAISE
FALSE CONCERN. BOTH OF THEM. IT
MIGUEL MARQUEZ THAT THE CEO OF
SANTA CLARA COUNTY. IN RESPONSE
TO MY QUESTION ABOUT WHAT'S
CAUSING THE BACKLOG TELLS ME OF
A CENSUS OF TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED
INMATES TWO THOUSAND FOUR
HUNDRED SANTA CLARA COUNTY AS OF
LAST WEEK TWO THOUSAND OF THEM
SHOULD HAVE RECEIVED A COURT
DISPOSITION ALREADY UNDER NORMAL
CIRCUMSTANCES SO THE COUNTIES.
NOT ONLY. DURING THE COST OF
THOSE INMATES FOR AN EXTENDED
PERIOD OF TIME BUT OBVIOUSLY THE
HUMANITARIAN CONCERN OF PEOPLE
OF BEING LOCKED UP- WHEN THEY
SHOULD ALREADY HAVE THE
DISPOSITIONS ARE CONCERNED SO
THAT'S WHAT'S DRIVING MY
QUESTION HOW DO WE GET THAT
MOVING BESIDES JUDGESHIPS.
SENATOR CENTER IS THE CENTER OF
THIS IS THAT ARE JUDGED THANK
YOU FOR RECOGNIZING ME I I'M THE
PRESIDING JUDGE IN SANTA CLARA.
AS YOU KNOW- AND CURVATURE IN
THE TRIAL COURT PRESIDING JUDGES
ADVISORY COMMITTEE. I THINK
YOU'RE QUITE SIR TO ME OR TO AND
TRYING TO ADDRESS THE NEAR IN MY
COULD. ON BEHALF OF THE BRANCH
AND ALL THE PRESIDING JUDGES NOT
JUST THE PRESIDING JUDGE IN
SANTA CLARA COUNTY BUT- TO ME
THIS CONVERSATION SPEAKS TO THE
- WHARTON'S. TO THE BRANCH-
SHORING DAY A CONSISTENT STABLE
EQUITABLE YOUR BASE LEVEL
OPERATIONS FUNDING TO.
EASTPOINTE AND THE PROPOSAL BACK
FUND- AS APPROPRIATELY ACCORDING
TO NEED RELATED TO BACKLOGS IS
FUNDAMENTAL TO HELPING NOT ONLY
SANTA CLARA COUNTY BUT ANY CORD
WITH THAT NEED TO ADDRESS THE
OPERATIONS- THAT HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED SO SEVERELY BY A
PANDEMIC. AND I THINK THE POLICYISN'T. AS PROPOSED AND WE
APPRECIATE THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCES ATTENTION TO IT AT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYSTS ARE
RECOGNITION. ABOUT NAY BUT
THANKS TO ME FOR THE TRIAL
COURT'S THE BASE LEVEL FUNDING
FOR THE JUDICIAL BRANCH AND THE
ATTENTION TO THE BACKLOG ARE
BOTH CRITICAL NEED FOR THE
BRANCH THIS TIME. IN IN IS IT
ENOUGH JUDGE ISN'T ENOUGH WHAT'S
PROPOSED HERE TO CLEAR YOUR
BACKPACK FOR EXAM. AND I KNOW
YOU'RE ANSWERING THE QUESTION ON
BEHALF OF. ABOVE ALL CAN SOURCE
GIVING ROLE TO. WHICH IS USING.
CELL KHARQAN IS AN EX. THE BAY.
AND IF NOT WHY NOT. I AM THAT
VERY DIFFICULT ANSWERED WITH A
YES OR NO IT WILL MAKE A
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT AS WE ARE
TRYING TO MAKE THAT IMPACT RIGHT
NOW WITH THE CURRENT LEVEL OF
SUNDAY. I CAN'T I CAN'T GIVE YOU
A DEFINITIVE ASSURANCE. NO I
WILL I'LL I'LL- GET IT WILL
ALLOW US TO CLEAR THE BACKLOG
THE QUESTION BECOMES. OVER WHAT
PERIOD OF TIME CAN WE ACCELERATE
THIS PROCESS AND I CANNOT ANSWER
THAT QUESTION DIRECTLY ON BEHALF
OF. OUR RECORD OUR CEO- BUT AS
YOU KNOW I'VE ALREADY BEEN IN
CONVERSATIONS WITH MR MARCOS AND
WE APPRECIATE YOUR OFFICES
ATTENTION TO BEST I'M HAPPY TO
TALK ABOUT THAT FURTHER- WITH
RESPECT OUR COUNTY. Q. DELETION
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR- CAN. GO AHEAD CENTER
NEWMAN AT PURCHASER COULD YOU
YOU FOR ANSWERED OF I CORPS BUT
MIKE WAS GOING TO BE ABOUT-
THERE'S LINE ITEM HERE COVERS
BUDGET FOR HOW MILLION. TO
PROMOTE FAIR EQUITY. ANSWER MY
QUESTION FOR MR OR OTHERS
SPEAKERS. AT AND AGAIN YOU
CANCER OF A DAY HOW FAR DOES
THIS GO- TO KIND OF TRIMMING UP
. YOUR BUT BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY
I MEAN WE HAVE A WE HAVE A
SURPLUS RIGHT NOW- AND THAT'S
NOT A YOU KNOW A GOOD THING-
BUT- IT ONE TIME FIXES YOU KNOW
CLEARLY POINT TO A NEED FOR
MORE. THOUGHTFUL STRUCTURAL
FIXES RIGHT SO HOW LONG DOES IS
GET YOU BUT MORE IMPORTANT I
THINK FOR MAYES WHAT ARE YOUR
THOUGHTS. ON ENSURING THAT AT
SOME FUTURE DATE DEGREE IT DID
AT SOME POINT WHERE WE MAY NOT
HAVE THE LUXURY OF A SURPLUS. BY
THE WE RATIONALIZE THIS. SYSTEM
SO THAT WE'RE NOT IN THIS
POSITION. YES YOU CENTER AND SO
WITH REGARDS. THE TWENTY FUNDING
AND THE- THE INFLATIONARY.
RIGHT- JUST AS WELL AS JUDGESHIP
IN THE BACK BUILT ON IT WHEN YOU
LOOK AT IT IN TOTAL- ARE
STATEWIDE AVERAGE RIGHT NOW FOR
FUNDING IS JUST OVER 80% OF WHAT
THE PROPOSED FUNDING OUR OUR-
STATEWIDE AVERAGE WITH JUMP TO
EIGHTY EIGHT PERCENT- WHICH IS.
A SIGNIFICANT. INCREASE AND WITH
THAT I THINK THAT YOU CERTAINLY
CAN EXPECT IMPROVE SERVICE
DELIVERY TO THE PEOPLE
CALIFORNIA- WITH REGARD TO OUR
ENSURING THAT THERE WON'T BE
CONTINUE NEED- AND QUITE FRANKLY
HOURS INFLATIONARY- IMPACTS.
AFFECT THE JUDICIARY- THERE WILL
LIKELY BE AN EROSION AT SOME
POINT WHERE WE MAY NEED TO COME
BACK TO YOU BUT I CAN SAY NOW
THAT- AS PROPOSED. THIS MAKES A
SIGNIFICANT- IMPROVEMENT TO THE
JUDICIARY- IN OUR CAPACITY TO
SERVE THE PUBLIC. AND JUST TO
FOLLOW BILL QUICKLY SEARCH AND I
WON'T HOLD YOU TO IT BUT
ROUGHLY. HOW MUCH TIME DOES IS
BY YOU RIGHT I'M I'M TRYING TO
GET A SENSE OF AS WE LOOK INTO
THE FUTURE. AND WE SHOULD BE AS
POLICY MAKERS THINK ABOUT A
SMARTER. AND MORE ACCURATE WAY
TO FIND THE JUSTICE SYSTEM YOU
KNOW WHAT'S THAT TIME I LOOK
LIKE WHEN WOULD YOU SAY- DATA
MINIMUM LIKE WE SHOULD BE
THINKING ABOUT THE NEXT PHASE.
TO MAKE SURE THAT WHEN I WAS
RESEARCHING A- ALL AT TO THAT IS
A VERY. QUESTION IN THAT- I
CAN'T FOR SEE WHAT THE
INFLATIONARY FACTORS WILL BE IN
THE NEXT FEW YEARS I WOULD THINK
THAT FOR THE NEXT FEW YEARS
THOUGH THAT- THAT SHOULD THINGS
REMAIN STABLE THAT THE JUDICIARY
WOULD BE AND VERY GOOD SHAPE-
ABOUT SAID AGAIN- CENTER I WISH.
I COULD BE MORE CLEAR WITH YOU
ABOUT THE ECONOMIC FORECAST OF
YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT'S PROJECTED
IN THE FUTURE- AND I APPRECIATE
THAT AND YOU KNOW IT'S I THINK
IT'S CLEAR IF WE PURSUE SOME OF
THE OTHER- DESIST SUBJECT AREAS
WE TALKED ABOUT PARTICULARLY.
FATAL EQUITY ON FINES AND FEES
YOU KNOW WE WILL PUT YOU IN A
POSITION RELATIVELY SOON SO IT'S
SOMETHING I WOULD ARGUE WE START
THINKING ABOUT NOW BUT I
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS. THANK
YOU SIR NEWMAN WHAT WE WILL DO-
BECAUSE WE'RE RUNNING LATE HERE.
WE'RE TRYING TO- REACH- THE END
OF THE AGENDA BY ELEVEN THIRTY-
BUT THESE ARE REALLY REALLY
IMPORTANT QUESTIONS NOT ONLY FOR
THE DISTRICTS REPRESENT MORE
IMPORTANTLY FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. RATHER THAN A
QUESTION I THINK I'LL JUST LEAVE
WITH YOU MY THOUGHTS THAT WE
NEED MORE SPECIFIC.
UNDERSTANDING AS TO HOW THIS ONE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR. EQUITY
FUND IS GOING TO BE USED ALL A
MORE NARROW. DEFINITION OF HOW
IT'S GOING TO BE USED- AND THE
SECOND THING I WANT TO BRING UP
IS WITH REGARDS TO THE NUMBER.
OF JOBS JUDGE SHIPS. THAT ARE
NEEDED AND THAT WE INTEND TO. OF
FILL UP WHAT STRIKES ME AS-
PRETTY. VERY SURPRISING IS THE
RIVERSIDE SAN BERNARD DINO AREAS
MAKE UP ABOUT HALF OF THE TOTAL
STATE WIDE. JUDGE NUMBER OF
JUDGESHIPS NEEDED- AND THAT'S
SHOCKING THAT AREA IS PROBABLY
THE FASTEST GROWING AREA IN THE
STATE. IT'S AN ENORMOUS
GEOGRAPHICAL AREA- AND I WOULD
REALLY LIKE TO HEAR NOT THIS
MOMENT. BUT HEAR BACK ABOUT HOW
WE INTEND TO. ADDRESS THAT IT'S
NOT JUST A MATTER OF CATCH UP
IT'S A MATTER OF GETTING AHEAD-
THAT'S AN AREA WHERE THERE WERE
THE- THE GROWTH OF THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE. ARE IS GOING TO CONTINUE
TO GROW RAPIDLY SO- THOSE ARE
THAT I WOULD LIKE TO BE.
REVISITED OUR GET RESPONSE FROM-
FROM THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL- THANK
YOU MR WARDLAW THANK YOU JUDGE
SINGER. AND MR HER AGAIN
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME HERE WITH
US AND- WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO THE NEXT ISSUE. THANK YOU.
OKAY. WE MOVE ON NOW TO ISSUE
THREE ARE HAS TO DO WITH- THERE
IS FACILITIES AND CAPITAL OUTLAY
PROPOSALS- AGAIN WE GO TO THE
GYM JUDICIAL COUNCIL. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
THIS IS ARTICHOKES ALL ISSUE ALL
ADDRESS THE FIRST ISSUE IN TERMS
OF THE STATE COURT FACILITIES
CONSTRUCTION FUND AND THEN WE'LL
HAVE OUR DIRECTOR OF FACILITIES
SERVICES. MCCORMICK ADDRESS THE
OTHER REMAINING ISSUES- HAS BEEN
DISCUSSED WE HAVE A FIND IN
FIJI- DECLINES- HAS SOME SORT OF
TALK ABOUT IN THE TRIAL COURT'S
FUNDING ISSUE- ONE OF OUR FUNDS
DISTRICT COURT FACILITIES
INSTRUCTION FUND HEAVILY RELIES.
ON THESE REVENUES TO STEP
SUPPORTERS EXPENDITURES WHICH
INCLUDE THAT SERVICE FACILITY
MODIFICATIONS AND OUR OVERALL
FACILITY STAFFING- DISPATCH.
FROM THE FORTY MILLION DOLLARS
WILL. VAIDA SOLVENTS FOR THIS.
IN THE BUDGET YEAR. WE KNOW THAT
WE'RE WORKING. WHAT WHAT'S THE-
ALLEGE TO LOOK AT THE TERM- BUT
THIS DEFINITELY PROVIDE- THE
NECESSARY RISK. IN THE BUDGET
YEAR TO. FIND OUR COSTS WELL
TURN OVER HELLO. MCCORMICK TO
TALK ABOUT YOUR JEWISH. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU- OUT OF AND
MEMBERS OF COMMITTEE IN INTENSE
TO THAT OF THE OF FUNDING BACK
BILL DID YOU CAL FACILITY
PROGRAM REQUEST CONSIDER OF TO
IT PROPOSALS- FIFTEEN POINT FOUR
MILLION ON GO FOR QUITE BILL
REPAIRS THE TRIAL COURT'S AND
TWO HUNDRED SIXTY THREE MILLION
AND CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS FOR.
FIVE NEW TRIAL COURT PROJECTS TO
CONTINUE THREE PREVIOUSLY
APPROVED PROJECTS THE ENGINE
THAT INCLUDES A CONCISE SUMMARY
OF THESE REQUESTS AND THE STATUS
OF THE ONGOING CAPITAL PROGRAM
AVAILABLE TO PROVIDE A DIFFERENT
DIGITAL INFORMATION OR TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONTINUED SUPPORT. THANK
YOU MISS MCCORMICK- ANYONE ELSE
FROM JUDICIAL COUNCIL MISTER
JIMENEZ. I'M IN THE FINANCE.
AND- WANTED TO PROVIDE OVER TO
THE ALLEY OF RECOMMENDED- DETAIL
OUT IN THE JANITOR- I WHICH IS
TO SHIP FULL RESPONSE FOR OR
CONSTRUCTION THE GENERAL FUND
WHICH IS NOT THAT THE- OF THIS
OR CONSERVATIVE KINDS BONDS IS
HOW A RESULT A BRA UP THE
DAUGHTER IN OF THE DECLINE
REVENUE FOR NOT THIS BUT OR
OTHER. FUNDS INCLUDING SPECIAL
FUNDS UNDER ANY SORT FOR LUNCH
BE CAN AN ABOUT CALL OF HOW TO
IMPENDING ISSUES FOR OTHER
SPECIAL. ON NOW BUT INCLUDES THE
FORTY ONE TIME GENERAL ON YEAH I
IN THE BUDGET TO THAT FILL STEPS
YES TO REMAIN SOLVED WITHOUT SIR
LEVELS THE BUDGET. OF ALL THE
DEVELOPED PERMANENT SOLUTION
ADDRESS INSTALLED NOT ON IN THE
SPA BUT OTHER THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISLI. I'M ANY WITH THE
LEGISLATURE ANALYST'S OFFICE
AGAIN- SO AS AS NOTED WE DO
CONCERN WITH THE LAWN TERM SO IS
AND THE PLANS IT'S NOT BEING YET
- AND THE SONG WILL WHITE
REQUIRE SIGNAL GENERAL FUND ON
ON BASIS FOR AS ABOUT TWO AT
LEAST YOUR MILLION ANNUALLY FOR
NEARLY A DECADE. JUST TO PAY FOR
THE DAY SERVICE FOR ALL COMPLETE
QUITE HOW. SO IN ORDER TO
PERMANENT ADDRESS LONG TERM SAW
OF THE COUNTRY OF DO RIGHT THE
CHEF FORCE FOR TRIAL COURT
CONSTRUCTION TO THE GENERAL FUND
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
WOULD NOTE- AND IN LIGHT OF THE
SENATORS AND DISCUSSION ON THE
PRIOR ISSUES IS THAT THIS IS
ACTUALLY CONSISTENT WITH OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS ON OVERHAULING
THE BROADER COMMERCIAL FINANCE
THE SYSTEM AND SO GENERALLY WE
DO THINK THAT. SHOULD BE
DEPOSITED INTO THE GENERAL FUND
AND OPERATING OUT SO CONSISTENT
WITH THAT FOR THIS PARTICULAR
CLIENT AND SHIFTING OVER THAT.
FOR RESPONSIBILITY THAT WOULD
INCLUDE. SHIFTING THE- AND ALL.
TO THE DOWN CLIENTS. READING THE
GENERAL- ANY DOLLARS TO ME AND
LEVEL OF SERVICE AND ALSO THE
ANY FOR THE REVENUE WOULD
OTHERWISE DEPOSIT INTO THAT
CONSTRUCTION ACCOUNT INTO THE
GENERAL FUND INSTEAD SO THEY'RE
STILL AVAILABLE TO OFFSET THOSE
SHIFTED COSTS AS A WIN THIS
AWARD- ENABLE THE LEGISLATURE TO
DO IS TO ENSURE THAT ALL
CONSTRUCTION RELATED OBLIGATIONS
ARE BEING FULLY ACCOUNTED FOR.
ONE WERE EVALUATING THE STATE'S
BROADER FISCAL CONDITION AND
DETERMINED AND WHEN THE
LEGISLATURE IS DETERMINING ITS
GENERAL FUND PRIORITIES.
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER YOU SHIFT
FOR RESPONSIBILITY OVER WE DO
RECOMMEND THAT THE LEGISLATURE
APPROPRIATE FUNDING FOR FACILITY
RELATED PROJECTS BASED ON ITS
GENERAL PLAN PRIORITIES. AND SO
IF THE FACILITIES FOR THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH IS A PRIORITY AS
USUAL GRANT HAS IDENTIFIED
SIGNIFICANT NEED- THE
LEGISLATURE COULD ACTUALLY
CONSIDER ADDITIONAL ONE TIME
FUNDING FOR QUICK FACILITY
PROJECTS SUCH AS FACILITY
MODIFICATION OR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE. BECAUSE OF THIS
TYPE OF SPENDING IS EXCLUDABLE
UNDER THE STATE OF CORPORATIONS
ONE. ABOUT SOMETHING THAT AND
YOU WANT JUST WANTED TO KNOW WHY
FREEDOM WILL BE HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOUNG. OKAY
FOR NOT TO A MICHAEL. YES YES
AND CRITICIZING THIS I'M TO MAKE
A CALL ON TAKE YOUR EXAMPLE MOVE
IN THE INTEREST OF TIME THAT IS-
I AGREE WHOLEHEARTEDLY WITH THE
- IT IS PART OF IT PICTURE OF
THE UP. BUSES THAT ARE OUT THERE
PAIN DEBT SERVICE- EIGHT IF
THEY'RE NOT GONNA BE ABLE TO
CLEAR BACKLOG I MEAN IT'S TIED
TOGETHER MAYBE THAT'S A STRONG
STATEMENT BUT THEY'RE GONNA HELP
LET'S SAY THEY'RE GONNA HAVE A
MUCH MORE DIFFICULT TIME
CLEARING BACKLOG. BUT IN THEIR
OWN SYSTEMS IF- WITH- USING
REVENUE FORCE TO PAY DEBT
SERVICE ON CON CONSTRUCTION AND
BE A BIG MAINTENANCE PROJECTS-
THE COMMENT I HAVE IS IN
ADDITION TO THAT BECAUSE I
BELIEVE THAT WE NEED TO LOOK AT
RETIRING DEBT SERVICE. FOR
CURRENT- PROJECTS OR PAT PASS
PRIZE- THAT THE- IS STILL BE
SYSTEMS ARE STILL PAYING FOR. IT
IT'S NOT GOOD ENOUGH TO JUST GO
FORWARD AND SAY. ANYONE IS
COMING IN WITH THE NEW PROJECT.
WE'RE GONNA SHIP THAT TO THE
GENERAL FUND. BUT BUT- YOU KNOW
ALL ALL- YOU KNOW- A NO GOOD
DEEDS FROM THE PASTOR GOING TO
BE PUNISHED- YOU COULD JUST KEEP
PAYING YOUR DEBT SERVICE ON ON
THE ON THE NICE TO COURTHOUSE
THAT YOU BUILT A FEW YEARS AGO I
DON'T THINK THAT'S FAIR ANYTHING
THAT NEEDS TO BE RESOLVED. IF
BEFORE GOING TO- IN A TO SOME
KIND OF AN OVERHAUL HERE IN
TERMS OF SHIFTING TO THE GENERAL
FUND THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR- FIFTY ONE HAVE- ANYONE
WANT TO RESPOND TO CENTER COURT
DISEASE. COMMENTS YEAH I'M ADAM
SCHIFF I MAY JUST TO CLARIFY THE
TRIAL COURTS ARE NOT RESPONSIBLE
FOR THAT PAYMENT OF THIS DEBT
SERVICE. AS A STATE AND JUDICIAL
COUNCIL RESPONSIBILITY WHILE
THERE MAY BE. A STORE GOAL
PROJECTS THAT HAD A COURT SHARE-
GENERALLY THOUGH THE PROGRAM IS
FUNDED FROM. THE STAFF AT THE
STATE LEVEL AND NOT A TRUCK OR
COSTS. I'M INCLUDING FACILITY.
MODIFICATIONS BILL IN IN MY IN
MY- SIR WE HAVE OVER ONE HUNDRED
DOLLARS DEBT SIR FOR THE FAMILY
COURTHOUSE IN DOWNTOWN SAN JOSE.
AND THAT WE'RE STILL PAYING ON.
IT AND WE JUST CAME OFF OF AN
ITEM WERE WERE. DELIBERATING
ABOUT SUBSIDIZING THE COURTS TO
CLEAR BACKLOG BECAUSE THEY DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH MONEY TO HIRE TO
HIRE PEOPLE TO CLEAR THE BACKLOG
SO. THE POINT I'M MAKING IS IT'S
NOT GOOD ENOUGH JUST TO LOOK
FORWARD- PATIENTS NEW
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS TO THE
GENERAL FUND YOU GOTTA GO BACK
AND LOOK AT THE INEQUITIES IN
TERMS OF WHO'S PAYING DEBT
SERVICE IN THE PAST. SO I DON'T
THINK IT'S- I DON'T THINK IT'S-
YOUR COMMENT THAT. THAT'S NOT
THE CASE IS AS ACCURATE IT IS A
CASE OF MY COUNTY AND- THAT FOR
A FACT. MISTER JIMENEZ ANY
COMMENTS. RESPONSE. I WAS JUST
ARE YOU KNOW WE MEETING WITH
KNOWLEDGE THE COMMENTS AND- WE
CAN BETTER WHICH WE CAN WORK
WITH YOUR STAFF TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND- YOUR YOU'VE GOT A HE
FURTHER YOU MIGHT HAVE AND-
GHENEAINFORMATION ME. THANK YOU
MADAM. THANK YOU SIR. OKAY I
THINK- SENATOR NEWMAN ANYTHING
OKAY ALSO WE DO HAVE I THINK IT
JUST TO SUM IT UP OR AT LEAST A
ONE POINT IS THIS LONG TERM
PLAN. WE SHOULD HAVE A LONG TERM
PLAN A MORE PERMANENT- PLAN ON
TAKING INTO ACCOUNT ALL THE
COMMENTS THAT WERE MADE TODAY
HERE BY THE COMMITTEE APPRECIATE
THAT- THANK YOU WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO. THE SHOE. FOR FOUR
FIVE AND SIX- THESE ARE REAL SO
EVEN THOUGH WE'RE GOING TO HEAR-
FROM THEM INDIVIDUALLY THEY ARE
SOMEWHAT RELATED SO WITH WE
COULD SAY THE CONVERSATION UP TO
THE END OF THE THREE AND I THINK
IT MAKES MORE SENSE IN TERMS OF
THE QUESTIONS THAT WE WILL HAVE
SO- THE FIRST THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL ISSUE FOR WILL PRESENT A
BRIEF OVERVIEW OF HOW THEY FIT
TOGETHER AND THEN WE'LL MOVE ON
SPECIFICALLY TO EACH ISSUE OF
JUDICIAL. COUNCIL. HI MADAM
CHAIR AND- NUMBERS MY NAME'S
ROBERT- YEAH I AM THE CHIEF
OPERATING OFFICER FOR JUDICIAL
COUNCIL I'LL PROVIDE YOU WITH A
QUICK OVERVIEW OF HOW THESE NEXT
THREE. PROPOSALS FIT TOGETHER.
EACH OF THESE THREE ARE
COMPLIMENTARY OF EACH OTHER BUT
THEY ARE DISTINCT STATE DON'T
OVERLAP AND THEY COVER DIFFERENT
ASPECTS OF THE COURTS BUSINESS
ENVIRONMENT. WE HAVE A MODEL FOR
CATEGORIZING TECHNOLOGY
INITIATIVES SUMMER BROAD BRANCH
BY PROGRAMS AND OTHERS ARE
INDIVIDUAL LOCAL PROGRAMS SO THE
PROPOSALS FOR IT MODERNIZATION.
DATA INFORMATION GOVERNANCE AND
REMOTE ACCESS FOLLOW THIS
STRUCTURE OF BRANCH BY TWO LOCAL
PROGRAMS STARTING WITH A BRANCH
WIDE PROGRAMS THAT DATA AND
INFORMATION GOVERNANCE PROPOSAL
FOCUSES ON ESTABLISHING A BRANCH
WIDE DATA PLATFORMS THAT WOULD
BE ABLE TO PROVIDE BETTER ACCESS
AND REPORTING TO BRANCH MY COURT
DATE. THE I. TEAM MODERNIZATION
PROPOSAL CONTAINS SOME BRANCH
WHY PROGRAMS SUCH AS THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH INFORMATION
SECURITY OFFICE ENSURE
TECHNOLOGY PLATFORMS THAT ALL
THE COURTS CAN USE SUCH AS
NOTIFICATION REMINDER SERVICES.
TO COMMUNICATE UPCOMING
APPOINTMENTS AND DEADLINES TO
THE PUBLIC. MOVING ON TO LOCAL
COURT PROGRAMS T. I. Q.
MODERNIZATION PROPOSAL ALSO
CONTAINS A PROPOSED FINDINGS.
FOR A LOCAL COURT INITIATIVES
SUCH AS CREATING MORE DIGITAL
ONLINE SERVICES. OR INCREASING
PUBLIC ASSETS CHIU INFORMATION
BY DIGITIZING PAPER RECORDS SO
THAT THEY CAN BECOME AVAILABLE
ONLINE AND THEN FINALLY THE LAST
. OUR PROGRAM FOCUSES ON REMOTE
ACCESS TO COURT PROCEEDINGS AND
THIS PROPOSAL RECOMMENDS THE
UPGRADE OF WIRING AND EQUIPMENT
IN THE OLDER COURT ROOMS ACROSS
THE STATE TO IMPROVE AUDIO AND
VIDEO CAPABILITIES. SO THESE
PROPOSALS OVERALL ARE RECOGNIZED
THE GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE AND
REPRESENTS THE MATURATION OF
BRANCH CAPABILITIES WE'RE PASSED
EMBARRASSMENT OF HELP THE COURTS
TO MODERNIZE PRESERVE ACCESS TO
JUSTICE BROUGH REMOTE
PROCEEDINGS. AND BEGAN
COLLECTING DATA ON A COURT.
USAGE AND PROCESSING AND SO WILL
GOING FORWARD WITH TO BE ABLE TO
CAN THESE. AND PROVIDE A STABLE
IN SUSTAINED ENVIRONMENT FOR OUR
USER. THANK YOU FOR MUCH I.
THINK OKAY SO WE'LL MOVE ON TO
THE SPECIFIC- ISSUE- ISSUE FOUR
WITH THE BRANCH WIDER APPRECIATE
YOUR THE CONNECTION THAT YOU
MADE SO THAT WE CAN STEP BACK A
LITTLE BIT AND THEN OUR DIVE
INTO EACH ISSUE NOW- MISTER
YOUNG ARE YOU GOING TO PRESENT
ISSUE FOR. ACTUALLY THAT WILL BE
A OTHER PENDANT OKAY. THIS
BETTER THANK YOU. THANK YOU ADAM
CHAIRING COMMITTEE FOR ALLOWING
US TO PRESENT ON ISSUE NUMBER
FOUR WHICH IS THE IT
MODERNIZATION. ASISTIR A YOUNG
MENTIONED THIS REALLY IS A
COMBINATION OF RANGE WIDE
INITIATIVES AND LOCAL INDUSTRY
CHAIR. CLEAR IT HAS. FIVE
SPECIFIC TO IT WHICH IT- THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF IT IS BRANCH.
SECURE OFFICE- AS WE KNOW IS
ABSOLUTELY GREAT OUR DAILY-
BRANCHES NOBODY THAN ANY TE
OTHER STATES AGENCY SO WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT CONTINUE RELY
AND IMPLEMENT NEW SHE'S
TECHNOLOGY. WE HAVE THE SECURITY
AVAILABLE TO PROTECT US AND THE
CITIZENS OF. THE IS ITEM THIS
OUT OF THE OF THE FIVE ACTS
SUPPOSED IN THE MODERN. OF YOUR
CORD AND THE COURT OF THE- THIS
IS AS- NEED WHERE. RIGHT NOW THE
COURTS APPEAL DO NOT RAISE ANY
FUNDING FOR ON OR TECHNOLOGY
INITIATIVES THEY ARE IN.
DESPERATE TO GET THESE MY OF
THESE INCLUDING OR MODOC TO
THEIR IT DOCUMENTS NEED TO
UPDATE CASE MANAGEMENT SYSTEMS
AND THAT RELATES AS WELL STAFF
TO ACTUALLY. ALL THE THAT HAPPEN
IN THE COURTS APPEAL THIS COURT
. THE THIRD IS RELATED TO LOCAL
COURT DOES WELL WHICH IS
PROVIDING. FOR INITIATIVES THAT
. THAT ARE HAPPENING AT THE END
TO IS A SMALL AMOUNT OF MONEY
ANNUALLY THAT WILL ALLOW THEM
CONTINUE TO SERVE. A TECHNOLOGY
IN. OR MODERNIZATION EFFORTS
THAT WE DO HAVE A BRANCH WIDE
LEVEL OR THE LOCAL LAW. I'M THE
FOURTH AREA IS. ON GRAND WHY
ISSUE YOU. MISTER YOUNG MENTION
THE- AUTOMATED MESSAGING
SERVICES THAT WE ARE ROLLING OUT
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE A COUPLE PORTS
THAT ARE JUST YOU KNOW. IT IS A
SOMETHING THAT WE WOULD TO
ACOSTA OR ANOTHER EXAMPLE WOULD
BE. ASSUME THAT MATCHES LIKE AND
COURSE THE OF THE LAW EXAMPLE I
WOULD PROVIDE WITH THAT WOULD BE
ESTATE. WHICH IS ALL OF THE
FIFTY TROPPER FINANCE SYSTEM.
AND THE ABILITY TO CALL. AND ON
A ON GREEN BAY SO YOU CHANGE AD
HERE TO TECHNO STATE AND-
STANDARDS. TECHNOLOGY OF ALL.
AND ALLOW ONE WHICH IS THE HE
WON FOUR APPS MONITOR. IS FOR
LOW COURT WHICH IS. THE ABILITY
TO RECALL TO TAKE. THEIR
BUSINESS NAY THEIR LOCAL COURT
NEEDS MAKE YOU TECHNOLOGY YOUR
CROTCH I HANSTEEN SERVICE FOR
THE PUBLIC. AN EXAMPLE THIS MAY
BE IN HERE WEBSITE SEARCH. OR IT
MAY BE. YOU KNOW SHE ALSO WHEN
YOU'RE WALKING INTO THE- TO HELP
. PEOPLE IT COULD BE. ELECTRONIC
DOCUMENTS IN THE DID YOU JUST OF
THOSE. WHAT WE DO KNOW ABOUT THE
- FOR THE FINALLY THE
LEGISLATURE HAS PER. ARE TWO I
EACH CORE OUT OF JAIL PLACE AND
TALK. AND THEY HAVE TO NEED.
THIS YOU KNOW FIFTH MARLYS.
PROJECT ALLOWS US WORK WITH
THOSE CORD TO BE ABLE PROVIDE
SERVICES THE PUBLIC. EXPECT IS
THE- OF THIS PRETTY REASON
REQUEST. AN ISSUE OF FOR. HI
MARK MANAGEMENT FINANCE- WE JUST
WANT TO REITERATE THAT THIS
REQUEST IS CRITICAL TO PROVIDING
ONGOING SUPPORT FOR FRENCH
FRIES- MODERNIZATION PROJECTS
THAT PROMOTE. IT'S ACCESS TO THE
COURT SYSTEM. ARDS TO THE
ELIAS'S RECOMMENDATION TO FIND
BRANCH LIKE I. T. BOB PROJECTS
AT THE DISCRETION OF THE
LEGISLATURE WE WOULD JUST LIKE
TO POINT OUT THAT THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL TECHNOLOGY COMMITTEE HAS
A RESPONSIBILITY OF ALLOCATING
ALL RESOURCES FROM THIS PROPOSAL
AND THEY ARE IS CERTAINLY WELL
POSITIONED FOR THIS ROLE BECAUSE
THEY HAVE A BACKGROUND AND
EXPERIENCE MAXIMIZE THE
RESOURCES PROVIDED TO AND-
PROVIDED AND CHIU CRISTINA
CHRISTENSEN STRATEGY TO ALLOW. A
TRIAL COURT'S ENGINE JUDICIAL
BRANCH TO MODERNIZE AND
EQUITABLE MANNER OF THE OUT WE
BELIEVE THAT THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL SHOULD HAVE THE
FLEXIBILITY TO SPEND ITS
RESOURCES ON AN ONGOING BASIS-
TO EFFECTIVELY PROVIDE CONTINUED
SUPPORT PROGRAM PROGRAMS- FATHER
WERE POINTED. THE TERM BASIS.
THANK YOU OBVIOUSLY- I NEED ONLY
ONE THE L. A. SO AS A OF MEN SHE
WE DO HAVE CONCERNS AWAY- THE
FOURTH AND FIFTH AND THEN WERE
IS LAID OUT ON PAGE OF YOUR DONE
ABOUT ABOUT TWENTY SEVEN GOING
TO THE JUDICIAL BROWN MODERNIZE
PROGRAM AND SO WE RECOMMEND THAT
THE LEGISLATURE MODIFY THE
PROPOSAL TO INCREASE LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT SPECIFICALLY UNDER THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL THE JUDICIAL
BRANCH WOULD HAVE ONGOING
DISCRETION ON THE USE OF A
DEDICATED POT I'M GOING FUNDING.
OF THIS REDUCES LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT COMPARED TO WHAT THE
LEGISLATURE CURRENTLY HAS NOW
PROPOSALS ARE GOING TO THE
ANNUAL BUDGET PROCESS MR THAT
PROCESS THE LEGISLATURE IS ABLE
TO ASSESS WHETHER EACH BUDGET
REQUEST ACCURATELY IDENTIFIES
THE PROBLEM OR NEED AND WHETHER
OR NOT YOU'RE BEING PRESENTED
WITH A COST EFFECTIVE SOLUTION
CLEAR OUTCOMES COMPLETE AND
ACCURATE COST AS WELL AS METRICS
TO KIND OF MEASURE WHETHER. IT'S
GOING SUCCESSFULLY- WE DOING
KNOWLEDGE THAT THERE IS SOME
BENEFIT TO PROVIDING DESTRUCTION
OVER A SMALL PART OF FUNDING
SPECIFICALLY THAT IT WOULD ALLOW
THE JUDICIAL BRANCH TED IT
QUICKLY TO RESPOND AS NEEDS
ARISE I WOULD ALSO ELIMINATE THE
NEED FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
CONSIDER REALLY SMALL PROJECTS
SO IN TERMS OF BALANCING THE
TWO- TO THE EXTENT THE
LEGISLATURE THINGS THIS IS A
PRIORITY WE WOULD RECOMMEND TO
THE LEGISLATURE INCREASED
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT BY
SPECIFYING LIMITS ON THE TYPES
OF PROJECTS THAT CAN BE FUNDED.
FOR CITING A TOTAL PER PROJECT
COSTS LIMIT ON PROJECTS THAT
COULD BE FUNDED FROM THIS PART
OF FUNDING AND SO THIS WOULD
LIMIT THE NUMBER OR TYPES OF
PROJECTS THAT COULD BE PURSUED
WITHOUT LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT
DURING THE ANNUAL STATE BUDGET
PROCESS WE WOULD ALSO RECOMMEND
REQUIRING ANNUAL REPORTING FROM
JUDICIAL COUNCIL ON WHAT
PROJECTS ARE EXPECTED TO RECEIVE
FUNDING AND HOW THE FINDINGS
WERE ACTUALLY USED IN THE PRIOR
YEAR AND THIS WOULD ALLOW THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONDUCT REGULAR
OVERSIGHT OF THE PROGRAMS TO
PROVIDE INPUT. IF THE
LEGISLATURE WAS INTERESTED
BEFORE FOR THE MONIES WENT OUT
AND ALSO TO I. REAS LEAD TO
ACTION MIGHT BE NEEDED OR DOES.
SO WITHOUT CONCLUDE COMMENTS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
LET'S SEE SHE WAS UP TO TAKE
QUESTIONS. COMMENTS OUR MOVE TO
ISSUE FIVE. OKAY YES IF WE COULD
ASK THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL TO
COMMENT ON ISSUE FIVE PLEASE. HI
MY NAME'S- ROBERT REALLY AYE
AGAIN CHIEF OPERATING OFFICER
JUDICIAL BRANCH I CAN COMMENT ON
ISSUES FIVE THE DATA AND
INFORMATION GOVERNANCE PROPOSAL
THIS PROPOSAL BUILDS UPON
PREVIOUS ONE TIME FUNDING TO
PILOT. DATA ANALYTICS PLATFORM
THAT WAS INITIALLY IMPLEMENTED
THROUGH AN INNOVATION GRANT
RECEIVED BY THE SUPERIOR COURT
OF ORANGE AND WE'VE BEEN
UTILIZING OUR EXPERIENCE WITH
THESE PILOTS TO COLLECT AND
ANALYZE DATA FROM PRE TRIAL
PILOT'S ABILITY TO PAY PROGRAM
AND THE BRANCH BY JUDICIAL
BRANCH STATISTICAL INFORMATION
SYSTEM OR JIM SAYS. IN MAY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL APPROVES THE DATA AND
INFORMATION GOVERNANCE POLICY
CONCEPTS AND THE BRANCH IS NOW
AGGRESSIVELY STARTING TO USE
DATA TO MANAGE ITS OPERATIONS
CONDUCT POLICY ANALYSIS CAN
TRACK AND MANAGE BACKLOGS SO
THIS PROPOSAL WOULD ESTABLISH A
STABLE ON ONE PLATFORM THAT
WOULD ALLOW US TO CONTINUE OUR
WORK IN THIS AREA. ARE EXPANDING
IT ACROSS THE BRANCH TO ALL
COURTS AN ADDITIONAL PROGRAM
AREAS SUCH AS SELF HELP JERRY
AND OTHERS AND THIS WILL RESULT
IN A MORE TIMELY DATA REPORTING
ARE REPLACING TIME CONSUMING.
MANUAL PROCESSES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- WE HAVE
FINANCED PLEAS. BERMAN BINANCE
NO COMMENT AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER JIMENEZ-
HOW ABOUT MISLI. THE CONCERNS OF
THIS PROPOSAL THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. OKAY. LET ME GO ON THEN
TO ISSUE SIX REMOTE ACCESS-
MISTER WILLIAMS. I SHALL HEADED
BACK TO A IS THAT IT OKAY MISS
BENNET. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
THAT HAD ABOUT A YEAR WHAT YEAH
HERE'S A COUNCIL SO THIS
PARTICULAR PROPOSAL IS RELATING
TO ELECTRONIC ACCESS TO REMOTE
ACCESS OR REPRESENTATIVES OR
PEOPLE WHO ARE OUTSIDE OF THE
COURTROOM SH ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE HAVE DONE WITH THE
MONETIZATION MONEY IS WE HAVE
ROVIDED. IN IT AT MECHANISM
CORE TO DO HEARINGS WE HAVE
INVESTED IN YOUR LICENSE ACROSS
THE BOARD SO THEY HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO GET IN POWER TO DO THIS
HOWEVER THE NUMBER ONE COMMENT
AND FEEDBACK THAT WE HAVE
RECEIVED FOR THOSE USING THE
SERVICE. IS THE QUALITY
SPECIFICALLY THE QUALITY OF THE
SOUND IN THE VIDEO THIS PROPOSAL
IS TO FIX AND ADDRESS THOSE
ISSUES WITH SOUND VIDEO SO THAT
THOSE FOLKS WHO ARE.
PARTICIPATING FROM A REMOTE
SPACE CAN ACTUALLY GET A LIKE
EXPERIENCE FROM THOSE WERE
ACTUALLY IN THE COURTROOM AND
THAT IS THE INTENTION OF THIS
PROPOSAL. SO THAT WECAN HAVE
CONSISTENCY ACROSS THE COURTS
FOR THOSE WHO WANT TO ACCESS
PROCEEDINGS IN THE COURT ROOM.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MUCH-
FINANCE PLEASE THREE MINUTES.
APARTMENTS APARTMENT OF FINANCE-
NO COMMENT AT THIS THANK YOU
OKAY MISLI. CONCERNS WITH THIS
PROPOSAL THANK YOU. OKAY SLOW
THAT'S THE END OF THAT ONE-
COLLEAGUES. QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS ON THIS NONE OKAY I
JUST HAVE ONE IF THERE'S A
SHORTER ANSWER OF THAT WOULD BE
GREAT- THAT MODERNIZATION
FUNDING- WAS. IT INDICATED SOME
USES RELATED TO REMOTE
APPEARANCES- CAN YOU CLARIFY THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THAT
FUNDING AND THE REMOTE ACCESS
FUNDING- WE'VE TAKEN UP THE
REMOTE ACCESS ISSUES IN THE
PAST- AND- THEY'RE VERY SERIOUS
ISSUES THEY REALLY HAVE TO DO
WITH- YOU KNOW ESPECIALLY-
EQUITY ISSUES WITH REGARDS TO
REMOTE ACCESS AND AN ACCESS TO
THE JUDICIAL SYSTEM SO COULD YOU
JUST ANSWER THAT ONE WHAT'S THE
CONNECTION. BETWEEN THE
MODERNIZATION FUND AND THE
REMOTE ACCESS FUNDING. YES THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR SO WITH THE
MODERNIZATION FINDING WE USE THE
ONE TIME FINDING TO ACTUALLY
BURKE SHEARER BRANCH WHITE
LICENSE GENE FOR REMOTE VIDEO
SOFTWARES TO RIDICULE ARCH THAT
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THAT IS THE
SOFTWARE IS AVAILABLE FOR TWO
YEARS HOWEVER THE INFRASTRUCTURE
FACILITIES WHICH IS THE HEART OF
THIS REMOTE ACCESS PROPOSAL. IS
STRUGGLING IT'S NOT IT'S OLD
IT'S OVER THE TWENTY YEARS THE
PROPOSAL FOR THE REMOTE ACCESS
IS FOR CORPORATE OVER THE TWENTY
YEARS OLD TO ADDRESS THE SOUND
ISSUES AND VIDEO ISSUE SO THAT
THEY CAN ACTUALLY UTILIZE THE
SOFTWARE THAT WE ARE PREPARED
FOR THE BRANCH SO THAT WE CAN
HAVE YOU KNOW REMOTE ACCESS
ACROSS THE STATE. IN A WAY
THAT'S A PRACTICE. OKAY GREAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR. ANY THE
COMMENTS REQUEST CALL NO- THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- WE WANT TO MOVE
ON NOW TO ISSUE SEVEN WHICH IS
OUR COURT OF APPEALS APPOINTED
COUNSEL- WE HAVE FROM JOY
JUDICIAL COUNCIL. ACCORDING
BROWN I'M SURE MY NAME IS LAURA
SPEED FROM THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
. GO AHEAD MS V. THANK YOU SO
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL IS
REQUESTING EIGHT POINT THREE
MILLION ONGOING GENERAL FUND IN
THE TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY
THREE BUDGET. TO SUPPORT THE
COURTS OF APPEAL COURT APPOINTED
COUNSEL PROGRAM. THE TOTAL
AMOUNT INCLUDES SIX POINT FOUR
MILLION. I'M GOING GENERAL FUND
FOR A FIFTEEN DOLLAR RATE
INCREASE HOURLY RATE INCREASE
THE NON CAPITOL HILL
APPOINTMENTS AT ONE POINT NINE
MILLION FOR A- PERMANENT TEN
POINT 5% INCREASE FOR THE
PROJECT OFFICE ANNUAL CONTRACTS
AND I'M AVAILABLE S THERE ARE
ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU OF MISTER YOU MENACE. MARTIN
IS A PERMANENT FINANCED NO
COMMENT AT THIS TIME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU- MISLI A CONCERNS OF
THIS PROPOSAL THANK YOU THANK
YOU I JUST HAVE ONE QUESTION-
WITH THIS INCREASED RATE- IF
IT'S NOT ENOUGH TO IMPROVE
RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION OF
COUNSEL. WHAT OTHER STRATEGIES-
HAVE YOU CONSIDERED OR WILL YOU
CONSIDER. WE'RE CONSIDERING
VARIOUS OUTRAGE DREADED USED TO
DIFFERENT GROUPS MORE- LOCAL LAW
SCHOOL LEVEL AS WELL AS
DIFFERENT TRAINING PROGRAMS TO
ALLOW A NEWER ATTORNEYS- TO GAIN
MORE EXPERIENCE IN THE PROGRAM
AS A MEANS OF ATTEMPTING TO
RETAIN NUMBER EARLIER IN THEIR
CAREERS. WELL THAT SOUNDS MORE
LIKE A RISK GOOD RECRUITMENT BUT
HOW DO YOU ADDRESS THAT OUR
RETENTION ISSUE. I'M I DON'T
KNOW THAT WE HAVE AN ANSWER FOR
THAT JUST DIRECTLY THE INCREASE
IS GOING TO ASSIST HOPEFULLY IF
WE GET THAT ROOMS AND- JUST
TRYING TO WORK WITH OF COURSE AN
HOUR EACH TO THE ATTORNEYS TO
GET MORE FEEDBACK FROM THEM
ABOUT- MAINTAINING- WORK IN THE
PROGRAM IT IS A COMPETITIVE
MARKET FOR THEM SO IT IS AN
ISSUE WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON. AND
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK ON FOR
PROBABLY SEVERAL YEARS HONESTLY
YEAH WELL I WAS I FOR ONE WAS
REALLY SURPRISED TO SEE WHAT THE
RATES ARE NOW- SO I'M VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THIS AND- HOPE WE
CAN COME UP WITH EITHER. OF MORE
INCREASES OR- JUST MORE WAYS OF
RETAINING THOSE ATTORNEYS. OKAY
THANK YOU MISREAD THANK YOU VERY
MUCH LET'S MOVE ON TO ISSUE
EIGHT. OUR VICTIM SERVICES
CONSOLIDATION. AND WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE- PRESENTATION BY- AND
CAL BCB. GOOD MORNING AND THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR HAVING ME HERE-
AS YOU KNOW THE PROPOSAL FOR
CONSOLIDATION WAS IN THE
GOVERNOR'S TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY BUDGET AND MANY THINGS
HAVE CHANGED SINCE THEN THINKING
ABOUT THIS ISSUE THE
ADMINISTRATION IS TAKING STEPS
TO FULLY ANALYZE IT PULLING
TOGETHER DEPARTMENTS IN THE
STATE START BUTTONS OF CRIME. TO
THROUGH HOW THEY SERVE VICTIMS
WHETHER THERE ARE OVERLAPS GAPS
OR NEED FOR CONSOLIDATION AND
GIVEN THAT AS A STATE WE'VE BEEN
FOCUSED SO MUCH ON THE RESPONSE
TO THE PANDEMIC WE'RE JUST
BEGINNING THESE CONVERSATIONS
AGAIN AND BUT WE WOULD BE HAPPY
TO KEEP THE TRADE. INFORMED AS
WE MOVE FORWARD. OKAY. DOES THAT
LA O'S OFFICE HAVE ANY COMMENTS. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR JUST
COMPUTERS WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE AND I WAS
MISLED HILL- INDICATED THE
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY BUDGET
I'M AT THAT PUT IN PLACE EIGHT
CONCEPTUAL FRAMEWORK FOR
CONSOLIDATING THE VICTIMS
PROGRAMS AT BOTH THE VICTIMS
COMPENSATION BOARD AS WELL AS
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES WHICH ARE THE
TWO DEPARTMENTS WITHIN THE
STATE. HAVE THE PRIMARY
RESPONSIBILITY FOR MOST OF THE
STATE'S VICTIMS PROGRAMS THERE
ARE SOME SMALLER PROGRAMS IN
OTHER DEPARTMENTS AS WELL- AND
THIS WAS AN AGREEMENT BETWEEN
THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
ADMINISTRATION HAVE PUT FORWARD
A REVISION PROPOSAL- IN THAT
YEAR- TO- CONSOLIDATE THE
PROGRAMS FROM THE STREET
APARTMENT. INTO A NEW DEPARTMENT
UNDER THE GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS
AGENCY ON THAT WAY AS A
CONCEPTUAL PROPOSAL AND WAS
AGREED IN CONCEPT AT THAT TIME
AND AT THE TIME THE
ADMINISTRATION HAD AND
DETERMINED IT WOULD NEED A
LITTLE BIT MORE TIME TO PUT
TOGETHER A FULL IMPLEMENTATION-
PROPOSAL AND WORK OUT SOME OF
THE DETAILS AND HAVE. A GREAT TO
PROVIDE A BUDGET PROPOSAL IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE FISCAL
YEAR TO IMPLEMENT BE CONCEPTUAL
AGREEMENT THAT WAS MADE IN
NINETEEN TWENTY THAT BUDGET
PROPOSAL WAS NEVER PROVIDED AND
IT HAS BEEN INDICATED HAS MISLED
HOME NOTED THAT THE ONSET OF THE
COLD IN NINETEEN PANDEMIC. HAS
SOMEWHAT SIDETRACKED ON THOSE
CONVERSATIONS AND SO THE
PROPOSAL WAS NEVER DEVELOPED.
AND SUBMITTED. JUST PROVIDE A
LITTLE BIT HE- I'M I AM I IS OF
THE US HERE BY. THIS IS AN ISSUE
THAT. AND COME UP- OVER NUMEROUS
TIMES. AT THE REQUEST OF THE
LATE. NUMEROUS OF THE
LEGISLATURE LOGISTIC STAFF HAVE
WORKED. EACH AND FOR ETTER OR-
ISAAC PRO- THE YEAR. I'M IN
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN THE BUDGET
REQUIRED. COMPETENCY BOARD AND-
YES TO WORK TOGETHER ON A PLAN
TO DO SO. IN TWENTY FIFTEEN OUR
OFFICE PUT OUT A REPORT- THAT
FOUND THAT HAVING VICTIMS
PROGRAMS PRIMARILY AT AND WE
ASK. COMPENSATION BOARD ON BEING
SEPARATED BY THOSE TWO
DEPARTMENTS REALLY LACKED
COORDINATION VICTIMS PROGRAMS-
RESULTING IN NUMEROUS ISSUES
THAT AT IT HAS THE STATE NOT
PROVIDING THE BEST SERVICE TO
VICTIMS SENATE COURAGE. AND IN
PARTICULAR WE FOUND THAT THE
STATE IS LIKELY LISTINGS AND
MISSING OPPORTUNITIES TO
MAXIMIZE FEDERAL DOLLARS BY
DRAWING DOWN VICTIMS OF CRIME
ACT FUNDING- THIS IS BECAUSE
THAT FUNDING IN THE DRIVE DOWN
TAKES PLACE UNDER COUNTY SEAT-
BUT SOME OF THE PROGRAMS UNDER
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES. PROVIDE
FUNDING FOR VERY SIMILAR
SERVICES BACK NAY QUALIFY FOR
THE STATE OKAY DOLLAR MATCHING
FUNDS- IN ADDITION WE FOUND THAT
HAVING NUMEROUS TIMES SMALL
PROGRAMS CAN MAKE ADMINISTRATION
THE PROGRAM'S INEFFICIENT. CAN
COMPLICATE THE ABILITY FOR AND
THAT TENDS AND THAT TIME SERVICE
PROVIDERS TO ACCESS SPENDING. BY
HAVING TO. APPLY FOR TO BRANDS.
AND SO- GIVE THE LEAD JUST AN
THE IMAGE HAD AGREED ON
CONSOLIDATE IN THE PARK WE-
SUGGEST YOU MAY TO GET IN FIRM
LINE THE NEXT. FIND OUT WHERE I
PURPLE WILL BE TO DO SO. SHE
THANK YOU MISS UP OF. DO GET
FROM THE DID MINISTRATION FOR
FINANCED YOU HAVE ANY. REASON TO
THOSE MORNING CLARK DEPARTMENT
FINANCE- WHAT IS OUT THERE ARE
BOGUS SPEECH TO BE ON CREATING A
BETTER EXPERIENCE FOR VICTIMS
AND ALSO- PAYING ATTENTION TO
FISCAL AND PROGRAMMATIC FISHES
THERE WERE FULL REPORTS AND- OR
WHAT CBS RECENTLY JUST SAID. IT
WILL CONTINUE IDENTIFIED THE
APPROPRIATE PROGRAMS THAT COULD
BE AFFECTED BY CONSOLIDATION. UP
TO YOU- DID YOU FIND ALSO THAT
WE WERE NOT GETTING AS MANY
FEDERAL DOLLARS- AS WE COULD OF
BECAUSE OF THIS SEPARATION OF
SERVICES. KEVIN CLARK BERMAN OF
FINANCE- I CAN'T SPEAK TO THAT
SPECIFIC POINT BUT WE WILL TALK
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT OUR FEDERAL
APPROPRIATION INCREASE IN THAT
UPCOMING PROPOSAL. OKAY AND THEN
OF A FINAL QUESTION FOR ME IS
HOW WHAT'S IN PLACE RIGHT NOW
THAT HELPS VICTIMS NAVIGATE
THEIR RESOURCES AT DIFFERENT
DEPARTMENTS HOW HOW DID HOW DID
THEY GET RIGHT NOW THE BEST
SERVICE THAT THEY CAN TO KNOW
WHAT IS OUT THERE AND AVAILABLE
FOR THEM. THANK YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION SO CARILLO YES IS MY
UNDERSTANDING PROVIDES GRANTS TO
LOCAL RESOURCES CHOPPY C. B. AND
WE PROVIDE DIRECT REIMBURSEMENT
FOR BILLS A FOR- EXPENSES
RELATED TO A VIOLENT CRIME- AND
AS WE HAVE NOTED THERE ARE MANY
OTHER ENERGIES WITHOUT SWITCHING
STATE GOVERNMENT THAT PROVIDE
DIFFERENT SERVICES- SO WE'RE
LOOKING AT ALL OF THAT IS TO
UNDERSTAND HOW THEY MIGHT WORK
BETTER TOGETHER- BUT OUR GOAL
CERTAINLY IS JUNIOR- BUT
TENSIONS NOW IN A SIMPLE EASY TO
UNDERSTAND WAY. WHERE THEY CAN
GET STATE RESOURCES. OKAY BUT
RIGHT NOW HOW DO THEY NAVIGATE
THOSE RESOURCES. SO INTERESTED
IN RESOURCES FROM US STUDY- THAT
CAN LEARN ABOUT US IN A LOT OF
DIFFERENT WAYS WE HAVE ENTITIES
AND COUNTY OFFICES WE HAVE. EASY
TO USE WEBSITE WHERE VICTIMS
TRAPPED BY ONLINE FOR I SUBMIT
AN APPLICATION AND WE ALSO WORK
CLOSELY WITH MINE FOR SPENCER
THAT THEY LEARN ABOUT OUR
SERVICES. AND I DON'T I DON'T
WANT TO SPEAK FOR CALAVERAS I
DON'T KNOW THAT THEY GET
DIRECTIONS THAT THEY HELP
VICTIMS DIRECTLY OUT OF
TRATTORIA. OKAY WELL. I THINK
THEM I THINK WE NEED TO KNOW
MUCH CLEARER MUCH CLEARLY MUCH
MORE CLEARLY. OF THAT- THE
VICTIMS WE CARE VERY MUCH I KNOW
WE KNOW AS PART OF THE- JUSTICE.
OF WORLD THAT IT IS NOT ONLY
THOSE WHO- ARE SERVING TIME BUT
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE THE
VICTIMS WE REALLY NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY KNOW. WHAT'S
AVAILABLE TO THEM ONTO THE
MAXIMUM AND- RIGHT NOW IT
DOESN'T SOUND LIKE WE HAVE A
VERY COORDINATED WAY OF GETTING
THAT INFORMATION TO THEM. SO
WOULD APPRECIATE THAT BEING
WORKED ON MUCH MORE SERIOUSLY-
COLLEAGUES. ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS NO OKAY THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISS GLEDHILL AND OTHERS FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION WE WILL MOVE
ON NOW TO ISSUE NUMBER NINE. THE
ARONIE US CONVICTION PROPOSALS
AND I ELIEVE FINANCES WILL MAKE
THE PRESENTATION. CORRECT GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AGAIN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE KEVIN
CLARK WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INCLUDES TWO DIFFERENCE
PROPOSALS FOR AN HONEST
CONNECTION COMPENSATION PROGRAM
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND BUDGET YEAR. AND STATUTORY
CHANGES TO PROVIDE RESOURCES AS
WELL AS AN EXPEDITED PROCESS FOR
COMPENSATING INDIVIDUALS WHO
HAVE BEEN ARRESTED CONVICTED OF
A CRIME. THAT.
THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- COLLEAGUES. NOT SURE.
RIGHT VISIT BEING SO QUIET. I
KNOW YOU PREPARE VERY WELL FOR
THESE HEARINGS- I APPRECIATE NO
I APPRECIATE VERY MUCH ALL THE
WORK THAT YOU PUT INTO THIS
OKAY- NEXT ISSUE IS NUMBER
ELEVEN A PEACE OFFICER
CERTIFICATIONS I BELIEVE- WE
HAVE SOMEONE FROM POST. HI GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR GUY WE'RE
JUST WAITING FOR EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR MANY OPERAS TO CONNECT
JUST A MOMENT PLEASE OKAY. THANK
YOU. YOUR PARDON LANDS IN WAS
NOT TO. IT'S NOT STARTING OUT
FROM. SORRY THAT'S THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE FACE MANY
TIMES PER DAY. NOTHING IS
HAPPENING I APOLOGIZE OKAY GOOD
AFTERNOON AT YOUR TO RISE SO
SOMEBODY MEMBERS AND STAFF ON
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS MANNY
ALVAREZ AND I SERVICE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE COMMISSION A
PEACE OFFICER STANDARDS AND
TRAINING PURPOSES WERE COMMONLY
REFERRED TO. I'M JOINED AT THE
HEARING BY MY COLLEAGUE JACKI
NELSON THE BUREAU CHIEF LEADING
THE POST IMPLEMENTATION TEAM WE
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY AT THIS HEARING.
HONESTLY TRY TO KEEP REACHING
KEEP BY KEEP IT LESSONS MINUTES
AND- TIME CRUNCH. WE WOULD LIKE
TO ADDRESS SB TO IMPLEMENTATION
PARTS FIRST JUST A FEW KEY
POINTS ON WHAT WE'VE DONE AND
WHERE WE STAND. AND SECOND THE
REASONS FOR THE REQUEST. IN THE
BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL. ONE
AUGUST THIRD PARTY SB TWO BEING
SIGNED INTO LAW WITH DESIGNATED
PART TIME TEAM TO HOLD MONTHLY
DISCUSSIONS ON IMPLEMENTATION
SHOULD THE BILL MOVES FORWARD.
NOVEMBER FIRST YOU DESIGNATE A
FULL TIME TEAM OF S. B. TODAY SB
TWO IMPLEMENTATION TEAM. THE
TEAM CURRENTLY CONSISTS OF EIGHT
FULL TIME PERSONNEL AND SEVERAL
PART TIME PERSONAL. IN DECEMBER
WE SHOULD BULLETINS AND SHE'LL
PROVIDE SOME OF THE NEW PEACE
OFFICER SELECTION STANDARDS
MANDATED MAYBE EIGHTY NINE AND
SB TWO. WE'RE IN THE FINAL
STAGES OF UPDATING THE POST
PEACE OFFICER PERSONAL HISTORY
STATEMENT. AND ARE NOW UPDATING
THE BACKGROUND INVESTIGATION
MANUAL TO COMPLY WITH THE
RELEVANT SB TWO REQUIREMENTS.
AFTER AN INVESTIGATIVE POLICY
MANUAL WHICH ENCOMPASSES BOTH
INVESTIGATIONS COMPLETED BY
PUBLISHED IN THOSE COMPLETED BY
LAW ENFORCEMENT DEPARTMENTS CHEN
VIEWED BY COAST. WE HELD TWO
WORKSHOPS IN JANUARY TO IDENTIFY
THE FACTORS TO BE CONSIDERED
WHEN REVIEWING. FIVE SERIOUS
MISCONDUCT FOR DECERTIFICATION.
THE FIRST WORKSHOP WAS HELD WITH
LAW ENFORCEMENT PERSONNEL. AND
SECOND WITH ADVOCATES FROM A
LIST PREPARED BY SENATOR
BRADFORD'S OFFICE. TO GAIN
KNOWLEDGE FROM OTHER STATE
ENTITIES WITH HOME ONE ONE
LICENSING DECERTIFICATION
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE FOLLOWING
STATES. WASHINGTON OREGON NEVADA
UTAH TENNESSEE NEW YORK AND
MASSACHUSETTS. OUR COMPUTER
PROGRAMMERS HAVE COMPLETED THE
DEVELOPMENT OF AN ONLINE
PLATFORM FOR THE RECEIVE
COMPLAINTS FROM MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC. LAST FOUR MODELED AFTER
THE EXISTING PLATFORM USED BY
DOJ. ALSO SUBMITTED A STAGE ONE
BUSINESS ANALYSIS TO THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT TECHNOLOGY
FOR THE ACQUISITION TECHNOLOGY
TO CAPTURE AND MANAGE THE DATA
ENUMERATED NASTY TO. OUR STAFF
IS DESIGNATED A FRAMEWORK FOR
THE FORTY HOUR TRAINING COURSE
MANDATED MANDATED FOR MEMBERS OF
THE NEW PEACE OFFICER STANDARDS.
ACCOUNTABILITY BOARD. THE
TRAINING REQUIREMENT WE ALSO
EXPECT TO PLACE ON POST STAFF
MEMBERS ASSIGNED TO THE NEW
STANDARDS AND ACCOUNTABILITY
DIVISION. WE ANTICIPATE ROLLING
OUT TO PILOT TRAINING COURSES IN
THE FALL. THE IMPLEMENTATION
TEAM IS DRAFTED TWENTY NEW
REGULATIONS TO ADDRESS THE
REQUIREMENTS OF SB TWO AMENDED
SEVEN EXISTING REGULATIONS I
WILL PROPOSE TO ELIMINATE ONE
REGULATIONS. WE SET AN INTERNAL
DEADLINE TO PUBLISH THE BOOK OF
THOSE DRAFT REGULATIONS FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT NO LATER THAN
MARCH FIFTEENTH. WE ANTICIPATE
THE PROPOSED REGULATIONS BEING
HEARD BY THE POLICE COMMISSION
ON MAY TWENTY FIFTH. OUR CURRENT
YOUR HIRING STRATEGY IS TO
INITIATE HIRING FOR ONE TWENTY
FOUR POSITION AND FOR H. R.
POSITIONS TO SOON AS POSSIBLE TO
SUPPORT SB TWO IMPLEMENTATION.
ID TWENTY FOUR WILL SUPPORT. I'M
SORRY YOUR TWENTY FOUR WILL
ASSIST WITH REGULATIONS AND
OPERATIONAL SUPPORT RELATED TO
SB TWO AND WILL STAND UP TO
LEGAL UNIT H. R. POSITIONS WILL
SUPPORT THE FUTURE HIRING OF
PERSONNEL SHOULD THIS BE CPB
APPROVED. FOCUS FOCUSING ON
HIRING FOR NEW HR STAFF WILL
HELP US PREPARE. FOR POTENTIAL
HIRING REQUESTED IN THE BCP.
WITH THE HIRING FOUR ADDITIONAL
HR PERSONNEL. ARE HR UNIT WILL
BE STAFFED WITH NINE PERSONAL
READY AND ABLE TO PROCESS LARGE
SCALE HIRING. FURTHERMORE WE
WILL ADVERTISE MANY OF THE
POSITIONS CALLED FORMS BCP IN
SPRING. THE CABBIE OUT TO
APPLICANTS HIRING WILL BE
CONTINGENT UPON THE FINAL
OUTCOME OF THIS B. C. P. IN
TERMS OF- OF THE REQUESTED HIS
PCP. WE'VE DONE DATA PROJECTIONS
ON THE VOLUME OF INCOMING DATA.
NUMBER OF REVIEWS WHICH WILL
TAKE PLACE AND THE NUMBER OF THE
CERTIFICATIONS. REVIEW I SOME OF
OUR EXISTING DATA AS WELL AS
DATA FROM OTHER STATES TO MAKE
THESE PROJECTIONS. THE
CHALLENGES SUCH THE POST. PRIOR
TO SB TWO HAS NOT BEEN REQUIRED
OR PERMITTED TO COLLECT THE DATA
LISTED IN THE LEGISLATION. TO
COMPOUND THE ISSUE EACH STATE
HANDLES THE CERTIFICATIONS
DIFFERENTLY WITH THE BALKAN
STATES PROCESSING REVOCATIONS
BASED ON CRIMINAL CONVICTIONS.
OR SUSTAINED INTERNAL
INVESTIGATIONS. IN OTHER WORDS
COMPARING DATA FROM OTHER STATES
IS IN PERFECT. THUS WE
UNDERSTAND THAT UNTIL WE HAVE
DATA WE MUST BE OPEN TO MAKING
ADJUSTMENTS. WE'RE HAPPY TO GO
INTO DETAIL ON OUR PROJECTIONS
AND HOW WE PLAN TO DEAL WITH THE
WORKLOAD IF YOU WOULD LIKE. TO
ACCOMPLISH THE MANDATES AND S.
B. TWO. B. C. P. ADDRESSES AMONG
OTHER THINGS THE NEED FOR
PERSONNEL RESOURCES TECHNOLOGY
AND OFFICE SPACE. A. B. C. P.
REQUEST FUNDING FOR ONE HUNDRED
TWENTY SEVEN NEW STAFF
POSITIONS. TWO MILLION FOR
TECHNOLOGY IN YEAR ONE AND ONE
MILLION ON GOING. AND ONE
MILLION ON GOING FOR SPACE. THE
REQUEST FOR PERSONAL RESOURCES
ONE ABLE POSTED CREATING LEGAL
UNIT STAFFED BY ANALYSTS
ATTORNEYS. IN AS MUCH AS WE DO
NOT CURRENTLY HAVE LEGAL STATUS.
WE WILL YOU KNOW WILL REVIEW
PROPOSED DECERTIFICATION
PATTERSON WILL WORK WITH THE NEW
ADVISORY BOARD. THE COMMISSION
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY WITH
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGES WILL
BE CONDUCTING EVIDENTIARY
HEARINGS. A. B. C. P. ALSO CALLS
FOR A NUMBER OF KEY UNITS SUCH
AS AN INTAKE UNIT TO RECEIVE
TRACK AND FOLLOW TO COMPLETION
ALL ALLEGATIONS OF SERIOUS
MISCONDUCT TO FIND. DETAILS
STANDALONE CERTIFICATE UNIT TAKE
ISSUE AN ADMINISTRATOR
ADMINISTRATIVE WE REVOKE
CERTIFICATES. A UNIT DEDICATED
TO REVIEW OF MATTERS PERTAINING
TO EXCESSIVE USE OF FORCE IN TWO
OTHER UNITS TO REVIEW ALL OTHER
MATTERS OF SERIOUS MISCONDUCT.
THE FUNDING FOR STAFF POSITIONS
IS OF CRITICAL IMPORTANCE.
STAFFING REQUIREMENTS LISTED IN
THE B. C. P. WILL ENABLE POST TO
FINALISE IMPLEMENTATION IN
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. AND WILL
ENABLE THE STATE TO MAINTAIN A
ROBUST PROGRAMS YEAR AFTER YEAR
. A. B. C. P. ALSO REQUEST
FUNDING FOR TECHNOLOGY AN
ADDITIONAL OFFICE SPACE. TO
ACCOMPLISH WHAT IS NOTED
EXCHANGING DATA WITH OVER SIX
HUNDRED AND FIFTY LAW
ENFORCEMENT DEPARTMENTS MUST BE
DONE ELECTRONICALLY. THUS THE
BCP REQUEST FUNDING FOR THE
ACQUISITION OF THE TECHNOLOGY
PLATFORM TO RECEIVE INFORMATION
TO CONDUCT REVIEWS AND
INVESTIGATIONS AND PERFORM CASE
MANAGEMENT CASE MANAGEMENT AND
ELECTRONICALLY STORED
DECERTIFICATION INFORMATION FOR
THIRTY YEARS JUST CALLED FOR IN
THE C. P. IN TERMS OF OFFICE
SPACE. POST IS CURRENTLY STAFFED
BY ONE HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE
PERSONNEL LOCATED IN ONE
PHYSICAL OFFICE SPACE. SECURING
SPACE TO CO LOCATE THE NEW
DIVISION IS AN IMPORTANT
PRIORITY. MAIN TAINING ONE
SINGLE OFFICE SPACE WILL
INCREASE PRODUCTIVITY AND ALLOW
POST MANAGEMENT TO EFFECTIVELY
MARSHAL RESOURCES WHEN NECESSARY
. WITH THAT MADAM CHAIR WE THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING US TO TESTIFY
YOUR COMMITTEE HEARING WE STAND
READY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR OF OTHERS THIS IS- QUITE
AN UNDERTAKING. AND APPRECIATE
ALL OF YOUR WORK FINANCE DO YOU
HAVE ANY COMMENTS. YES GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE ANY FRIENDS
WITH THE PARTNER FINANCE- ALWAYS
I WOULD ECHO ALL TRUCK- VERSUS
POINTS- BUT TO RESPOND TO SOME
OF THE ALLEY I WAS CONCERNED
THAT ARE NOTED IN YOUR AGENDA-
THE ADMINISTRATION IS NOT
BELIEVE THAT THE ONE TIME SURGE-
AS I MADE HIM TO REALISE AS THE
ELLIE I DESCRIBE. FOR A COUPLE
OF REASONS THE FIRST REASON
BEING THAT- THE ISSUANCE OF THE
PROOF OF ELIGIBILITY ON JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY THREE POSTS
WILL BE ABLE TO ADDRESS
AFTERWARD AUTOMATED PROCESS
THEREFORE REDUCING THE IMPACTS
OF POTENTIAL SURGE- THE SECOND
PIECE RELATES TO THE REVIEWING
OF THE RETROACTIVE REPORTS
EXPECTED FOR ALLEGATIONS OF
SERIOUS MISCONDUCT. THAT
OCCURRED PRIOR TO JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY THREE. THESE
REPORTS ARE NOT DUE TO POST- ARE
THIS ARE THEY ARGUED OPPOSE
STARTING ON JANUARY FIRST EIGHTY
AND MUST BE SUBMITTED BY JULY
FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY THREE.
AND SO WHAT POST IS EXPECTING IS
TO RECEIVED SOME REPORTS ON A
FLOW BASIS STARTING ON JANUARY
FIRST- BUT NOT ALL AT ONE TIME
THERE FOR AGAIN- DIMINISHED
SCENE- THE INSTANCE RESEARCH.
AND THEREFORE WE'RE CONFIDENT
POSSIBILITY TO ABSORB THIS
WORKLOAD. WITH A STATUS PROPOSED
BCK. THE SECOND OVERARCHING
POINT IS THE L. A. WAS CAN.
REGARDING PO HE TOOK PAINS
STATUS. ALSO OPPOSES THAT WILL
BE ABLE TO OBTAIN THIS SPACE.
QUICKLY AND IT'S BEEN. WITH OUR
PARTNER SERVICE- ANY. STUDIES
THAT. TO BE EXTENDED TASTE POST
LONGER TO OBTAIN THIS STAYS. CAN
LEVERAGE SOME CREATIVE SOLUTIONS
INCLUDING REPURPOSING EXISTING
WORKSPACE- HOTEL AND CUBICLES.
AND WEBER INTEL WORK TO
ACCOMMODATE THE DISTRICT STAFF.
AND LASTLY THAT THIRD POINT IS
IN RESPONSE THE L. IS CONCERNED.
ABOUT POSSIBILITIES YOU HIRE ON
BOARD- THE HUNDRED TWENTY SEVEN
POSITIONS. BY JANUARY FIRST- WE
KNOW THAT THIS IS A BIG
CHALLENGE POST AGAIN HAS BEEN
ENGAGING WITH KALINJAR- EARLY
ON- TO DEVELOP SOME STRATEGIES.
TO RECRUIT HIRE AND TRAIN THE
NECESSARY STAFF- AGAINST
INDIVIDUALS UNDERTAKING GIVEN
THAT REPRESENTS A NEAR DOUBLING
OF THE STAFF. BUT AGAIN POLICIES
BE DOING- WORK ALREADY AND WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK DILIGENTLY. TO
DO SO WITHOUT COMPLETE MY
COMMENTS AND. ACCOUNTABLE FOR
ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OF THE OF THE L. A.
L. PLEASE MISS PETERS. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR I SO IT TO KIND OF
TOUCH ON THE CONCERNS THAT MR
FRIENDS AWAY AT ADAMS SORT OF
SHOULD I TEACH THANK YOU FOR
THAT. WE WANT TO FIRST KNOW THAT
POST OFFICE MR ALVAREZ'S
INDICATED HANSTEIN I'M REALLY
ENCOURAGING AMOUNT OF WORK SHE
COMPLIMENTS THIS NEW PROGRAM I'M
IN A IN A VERY SHORT AMOUNT OF
TIME. THEY HAPPEN THAT WAY ASK
THAT OFFICIALS IN OTHER STATES
WITH SIMILAR PROGRAMS AND REALLY
DONE A LOT OF WORK IN THE
CURRENT YEAR OR WITHOUT HAVING A
SIGNIFICANT AUGMENTATION OF
RESOURCES. IN ORDER TO GET THE
PROGRAM TO STOP AND SO WE WANT
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT WE THINK
THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO OUT. WE
DO RECOMMEND HAVING AT THE
ADMINISTRATION SUBMIT A REVISED
PROPOSAL FOR CLOSE RESOURCES
TEMPLE MAY I SPEAK TO INTIMIDATE
TO IDENTIFY AND ADDRESS SOME OF
THE ISSUES THAT WE'VE IDENTIFIED
WITH THE PURPLE SOCKS. FIRST AS
WAS ALLUDED TO- THE PROPOSAL
DOES NOT ADDRESS FOR A SURGEON
WORKLOAD SETTLE BEACH- STAFFING
LEVELS THAT HAVE BEEN REQUESTED
ARE REFLECTIVE OF THE ESTIMATES
ONGOING WORKLOAD SHAUN BASED ON
THOSE CONVERSATIONS THAT POSTERS
HAVE WITH OTHER STATES AND THAT
TYPE OF WORKLOAD IN SIMILAR
PROGRAMS. ON AND THEN ADJUSTED
INFORMED BY THE NUMBER OF
AGENCIES AND OFFICERS IN
CALIFORNIA. AND SO OBVIOUSLY IT
WITH A NEW PROGRAM AND IT IS
JUST AN ESTIMATE WE DON'T HAVE
ANY ISSUES WITH THOSE I'M GOING
ESTIMATES AT THIS TIME- BUT WHAT
WE WOULD NOW AND AS I MISTER
FRIENDS WE INDICATED. IS THAT-
ALL RIGHT FOR ME AGENCIES IN THE
STATE UNDER S. BEACH YOU WILL BE
REQUIRED TO NOT ONLY REPORT ON
DOWNEY ON ALLEGATIONS ASSIST
SERIOUS MISCONDUCT BUT TO REPORT
AND THREE YEARS OF PRIOR TO THAT
ON ALLEGATIONS OF SERIOUS
MISCONDUCT AND SO THOSE WILL
START COMING IN JANUARY ONE. AND
AGENCIES WILL HAVE AS WAS.
INDICATED A SIX MONTHS TO
PROVIDE. SO WITHIN THE FIRST SIX
MONTHS OF THE- GOING WHAT THREE
YEAR OF OUR- WILL BECOME TO
COAST. FOR THEIR REVIEW AND THE
TEN AND- IN ADDITION IT MAY. OF
THE PUBLIC- OR EVEN UNDER HAS
TWO BEGINNING JANUARY ONE OF
NINETY YEAR. TO MAKE IT WORK.
ALLEGATIONS OF SERIOUS
MISCONDUCT IRAQ TO POWER. BOTH
ON A ONGOING BASIS I WELL AS
FOR. POTENTIAL PASSED SERIOUS
MISCONDUCT THAT OCCURRED. IN OUR
INNER STANDING ON THAT IS THAT'S
NOT EVEN LIMITED TO THAT THREE
YEAR ANY PAST SERVICE
MISCONDUCT. FROM AN OFFICER. ON
AND STILL NOT ACCOUNTING FOR
THAT WORKLOAD AND ONLY BASING
THE STAFFING REQUESTS ON. THE ON
GOING WORKLOAD. THREE A CONCERN
US. IN ADDITION- AS IN. WHAT
CLOSE IS WORK ON OPTIONS STREAM
D. ONE CERTIFICATION WORKLOAD ON
THE LEGISLATURE IS GONNA WANT TO
ENSURE THAT THAT TIME IS DONE IN
A TIMELY MANNER AS WELL AS THERE
ARE SEVERAL THOUSAND OFFICERS
THAT ARE NOT CURRENTLY CERTIFIED
BY POST I THAT WOULD NEED TO BE
CERTIFIED BY JANUARY ONE OF THE
NEXT YEAR WHEN THE PROGRAM
SLASH. IN ADDITION WE FOUND THAT
THERE ARE SOME POTENTIAL
IMPLEMENTATION CHALLENGES WITH
THE LEGISLATION AGAIN AT A POST
IS VERY AWARE NEEDS AND SEEMS TO
BE WORKING VERY DILIGENTLY TO
ADDRESS THEM. NONE THE LAST WE
THINK THAT EFFECTIVE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE PROGRAM
WILL BE EXTREMELY IMPORTANT TO
INSTILL PUBLIC TRUST IN THE NEW
PROGRAM AND ENSURE THAT
ALLEGATIONS OF MISCONDUCT ARE
REVIEWED IN A TIMELY MANNER
COMMENTS OF THE LEGISLATURE IS
GONNA WANT TO. HAVE SOME
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION WE THINK
ON HOW THESE IMPLEMENTATION
CHALLENGES WILL BE ADDRESSED ON
THE SPECIFIC CHALLENGES RELATE
PRIMARILY AROUND THE NEED TO
ROUGHLY DOUBLE THE SIZE OF STAFF
STAFF WITHIN SIX MONTHS. AS MR
OPERATES INDICATED HOWEVER- POST
IS PLANNING A SOMEWHAT PHASED
APPROACH TO HIRING THE STAFF I'M
INCLUDING SOME OF THE STOCKS
THAT ARE IDENTIFIED IN THE
BUDGET PROPOSAL POTENTIALLY
BEING HIRED IN THE CURRENT YEAR
AS I BELIEVE TWICE- I'VE SPOKEN
TO- AND MISTER ALVAREZ'S
PRESENTATION AND AS WELL AS SOME
OTHER INFORMATION THAT WE HAVE
HEARD FROM POST THAT NOT ALL THE
POSITIONS WILL NECESSARILY BE-
ON BOARDED- WITHIN THE FIRST SIX
MONTHS OF THE YEAR. I'M FROM THE
TIME THE BUDGET PASSES TO WHEN
THE PROGRAM GOES LIVE ON JANUARY
ONE I'M AND WE WOULDN'T KNOW IF
THAT THE. BUDGET PROPOSAL
DOESN'T REFLECT THIS. APPROACH
ON- UP THE- AND SO IT WILL
REALLY BE ON FOR THE- UNDER THAT
TIME AND NOT PLEASE APPROACH.
AND HOW THAT ALIGN WITH THE X.
WORKLOADS WILL BE CAN CAN MEAN
AND I JANUARY ONE OF NEXT YEAR.
IN ADDITION WILL COAST HAS
REQUESTED FUNDING FOR AN IT
SYSTEM AND WE UNDERSTAND THAT
THEY HAVE BEEN WORKING
DILIGENTLY. TO AND GET TO BE A
FOUNDATION LAID FOR PROCURING AN
EIGHTY SYSTEM QUICKLY. FROM THE
POINTTHAT THE FUNDING IS
PROVIDED IF THIS EASY PIZZA
APPROVED- ON JULY ONE TO WIN THE
SYSTEM WE NEED TO BE PROCURED AN
OPERATIONAL COST ONLY HAVE SIX
MONTHS WHICH FOR AN EIGHTY
PROJECT IS. A SHORT AMOUNT OF
TIME AND SO THE LEGISLATURE IS
GOING TO WANT TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
CONTINGENCY PLANS POST HASN'T
PLACED. FOR THAT IMPORTANT
PIECE. THAT WAY THAT RELATE TO
THE REPORTING INFORMATION FROM
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES WE
WOULD KNOW AND CREDIT HOST WITH
ITS OXFORD STREET CREATIVE
RECORDING. SYSTEM FOUR REPORTS
COMING IN FOR MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THAT THEY'VE DEVELOPED IN
HOUSE AND HAVE REACHED ALL. TIME
WHICH IS ANOTHER EXAMPLE
ANSWERED THE ENCOURAGING PROCESS
THAT PROCESS PROGRESS THAT THEY
HAVE MADE IN IMPLEMENTING THIS
PROGRAM- AND THEN LASTLY IN
TERMS OF IMPLEMENTATION
CONCERNS- OFFICE SPACE WAS
DISCUSSED- BY MISTER AUTHORIZED
AND- THE PROPOSAL FOR YOU
DOESN'T COULD FUNDING FOR OFFICE
SPACE. HOWEVER IT'S BEEN NOTED
TASK THAT IDG **** AND WORK POST
IT COULD TAKE A YEAR OR MORE
ACTUALLY WE ARE PRETTY SURE THE
OFFICE SPACE AND SO POSTED ON
OBVIOUSLY HAS BEEN THINKING
ABOUT SOME CONTINGENCY PLANS FOR
HOW TO STAFF NEED NEW PLEASE
HOWEVER THE LEGISLATURE WE THINK
IT'S GONNA WANT MORE INFORMATION
ON THAT AND- BE ABLE TO DO SOME
OVERSIGHT OF THAT. AND SO WE
WOULD RECOMMEND HAVING SUBMIT
REVISED PROPOSAL AT ANY REVISION
TO ADDRESS BOTH THE US SEARCH
AND WORKLOAD- AND ONE TIME
WORKLOAD. AS WELL AS THE PHASING
IN OF STAFF. AND ADDRESSING
THESE IMPLEMENTATION CHALLENGES
SO THAT THE LEGISLATURE CAN
ENSURE THAT HOST. IS RECEIVING
THE RIGHT WELL I SERVICES ON THE
RIGHT LANE OF ENSURE. EMPLOYMENT
OF THIS HAS A GOES LIVE NEXT
YEAR. AND HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
THAT YOUNG. THANK YOU MISS
PETERS- JUST BACK TO MISTER
ALBERT IS THERE ANY THAT YOU
WANT TO SEE AND WE- I KNOW THERE
WERE. BECAUSE BY FINANCE BUT ANY
THAT YOU TO ADD IN RESPONSE THE
ALEJO. YES MA'AM I THINK IN
TERMS OF TAKE A AT LEAST A SPACE
ISSUE- FIRST OF ALL WE DID SOME
RECONFIGURATION OF SPACE ISSUE
OF OUR SPACE IN TWENTY TWENTY.
TWENTY ONE- IT IS OCCUPIED SPACE
FOR THE MOST PART WE HAD SOME
TEMPORARY THE SB TWO TEAMS
WORKING IN THAT SPACE WITH THE-
OUR LIBRARY THAT WAS IN OUR
BUILDING IN ADDED THIRTEEN
CUBICLES FOR DOING ANOTHER
RECONFIGURATION HEARING MARCH AS
PART OF A- PLEASE HOLD. CAN
IMPROVEMENTS ARE NEEDED LEASE
IT'S GONNA. GIVE US ANOTHER TO-
WORK SPACES I'VE COUNTED UP OUR
OUR CUBICLE SPACES IF WE'RE
FULLY STAFFED TODAY WE STILL
HAVE AN ADDITIONAL THIRTY
CUBICLES. TO TO. INCLUDE NEW-
NEW EMPLOYEES INTO FOUR SP TWO
ADDITIONALLY WE'RE ALSO WORKING
. TELEWORK WE'RE ON A HYBRID
TELEWORK AT PROGRAMS- WE'VE BEEN
ON HYBRID TELEWORK SINCE SAID
SINCE THE INCEPTION COBEN FACT
FIRST YEAR EVERYBODY'S
TELEWORKING WE CAN OBVIOUSLY.
INCORPORATE THE EXISTING SPACE.
COME TO SOME OF THE EXISTING
SPACE USING A HYBRID TELEWORK
MODEL SO THAT ALL PUPILS HER OUT
ARE FULLY OCCUPIED SO THE SPACE
CONCERNS ARE NOT. SIGNIFICANT
ISSUE FOR ME PERSONALLY IN TERMS
OF THE- THE SURGE OF RECORDING
CELLS WILL LET ME TAKE THE PROOF
OF ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS THAT
ARE SET ON CLOTHES FOR JANUARY
ONE WE'VE ANTICIPATED THAT
THERE'S FOUR THOUSAND PROOF OF
ELIGIBILITY CERTIFICATES THAT WE
NEED TO ISSUE THOSE WILL ALL BE
ISSUED AUTOMATICALLY- ON
AUTOMATED. USING OUR AUTOMATED
SYSTEM TO ISSUED AS PROOF OF
ELIGIBILITY CERTIFICATIONS TO
EXISTING EMPLOYEES DO NOT HAVE
THEIR BASIC CERTIFICATE SO THAT
IS ALREADY KIND OF IN THE WORKS
DONE I MEAN IT'S REALLY JUST A
MATTER OF- YOU KNOW DOING IT ON
JANUARY ONE BASICALLY ALLOWING
THE SYSTEM TO ISSUE DOES. IN
TERMS OF THE WORKLOAD IN THE NEW
INFORMATION COMING IN- FOR
RETROACTIVE- REPORTING AND I
WOULD LIKE OUR BUREAU CHIEF
THANK JACQUI NELSON TO SPEAK TO
THAT BUT IT IS GOING TO BE A
PHASE DAY NOT A PHASED IN. I
BELIEVE THE MR FRIENDS- YET TALK
ABOUT A FLOW OF INFORMATION
COMING AND WE DON'T ANTICIPATE
THAT THAT INFORMATION IS ALL
GOING TO. ARRIVE ON JANUARY ONE
MAY HAVE A SIX MONTH REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS AND THEN THERE ARE
CERTAIN LIMITATIONS ON WHAT WE
CAN DO WITH THAT RETROACTIVE
INFORMATION THAT'S HOPEFULLY
WHAT I. CAN LEAN ON- JACQUI TO
SPEAK TO. IN TERMS OF THE- THE
HIGHER- WE'RE GONNA TRY TO HIRE
AS MANY PEOPLE AS WE POSSIBLY
CAN- STARTING. AS SOON AS SAYS
APRIL WE ALSO ANTICIPATE THAT
THE DIVISIONS CAN BE STAFFED BY
SOME EXISTING PERSONNEL WITHIN
PULSE IT'S NOT ALL GOING TO BE
BRAND NEW STATE EMPLOYEES OR NEW
POST EMPLOYEES SOME OF THEM ARE
GOING TO TRANSFER OVER FROM THE
EXISTING POST POSITIONS.
OBVIOUSLY THAT CREATES VACANCIES
ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THE HOUSE
BUT WE DO FEEL THAT WE ARE
POSITIONED IN A GOOD SPOT. TO BE
READY ON JANUARY ONE WE ALSO
WANT TO HAVE SOME FLEXIBILITY IN
TERMS OF HOW WE HIRE- AND HOW
MANY WE CAN HIRE HOPEFULLY WE'LL
BE AHEAD OF THE- I HAD A
SCHEDULE AND BE ABLE TO HIRE
MORE THAN WE WOULD LIKE. BY
JANUARY ONE. BUT WE DO WANT TO
HAVE THAT FLEXIBILITY TO BE ABLE
TO HIRE AS MANY AS POSSIBLE AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE. JACKIE FOR
MAKING YOU. JUMP IN AND HANDLE
THE- THE RETRO ACTIVE IN ANY
OTHER CERTIFICATION ISSUES FOR
DECERTIFICATION ISSUES THANK YOU
. YES THANK YOU. AND GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS AND
STUFF COMMITTEE MY NAME'S JACKIE
NELSON AND I AM THE BUREAU
CHIEF. HAVING THE SB TWO
INFORMATION IMPLEMENTATION ON
BEHALF OPPOSED SO BRIEFLY
REGARDING THE RETROACTIVITY OF
CASES. DURING THAT SIX MONTH
REPORTING. CRITERIA ARE
REPORTING TIME PERIOD- DAY
AGENCIES WILL BE REQUIRED TO
REPORT ANY. MISCONDUCT THAT
FALLS WITHIN THE DEFINITION OF
SERIOUSNESS CONTENT. TO POST.
BUT IT IS IMPORTANT TO POINT OUT
THAT- ANY ACTION UNDER-
MISCONDUCT THAT OCCURRED BERMAN.
JANUARY ONE OF TWENTY TWENTY
TWO. WE MAY ONLY TAKE ACTION
AGAINST VERY SPECIFIC.
CATEGORIES AND THAT MISCONDUCT.
THAT MEAN DISHONESTY. ACTUAL AND
EXCESSIVE USE OF DEADLY FORCE
RESULTING IN SUBSTANTIAL BODILY
HARM OR DEATH SO. AMONG THE
ALLEGATIONS THAT WE EXPECT TO
RECEIVE WITH AND NOT RETROACTIVE
REPORTING TIMEFRAME WE WILL ONLY
NEED TO. MORE ONLY AUTHORIZED TO
TAKE ACTION AGAINST THREE OF
THOSE AREAS ON ANYTHING REPORTER
PRIOR TO JOINING THE ONE IT'S
ONE TWENTY TWO. THANK OKAY-
COLLEAGUES ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. OKAY WONDERFUL OKAY
WELL I APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU
MISTER IS AND OTHERS FROM THE-
DEPARTMENT FOR ALL THAT YOU'RE
DOING- AND SOUNDS LIKE YOU'RE
WELL ON YOUR WAY AND VERY
THOUGHTFUL ABOUT ALL THE ISSUES
AND ALSO APPRECIATE THE L. A-
SAW SPECIFIC- RECOMMENDATIONS
THANK EVERYBODY. AND WE MOVE ON
NOW TO ISSUE NUMBER TWELVE WHICH
IS OFFICER WELLNESS AGAIN I
THINK THIS IS THAT YOU MISTER
ALBERT IS. YES MA'AM AND THAT
HIGH I WILL KEEP THIS ONE A
LITTLE BIT SHORTER THAN THE LAST
ONE. MADAM CHAIR FOR THIS
TESTIMONY I'M JOINED BY. TEARING
BY MY COLLEAGUE INTERNMENT
JOHNSON WHO IS COORDINATING OUR
EFFORTS ON. THE SMALLEST
TRAINING. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THE
SECOND B. C. P. WE WILL BE BRIEF
AND WILL ADDRESS WILL BE DONE IN
TERMS OF WELLNESS AND SECOND THE
REASONS FOR THE RESOURCE REQUEST
IN THIS B. C. P. OUR WAY OF
BACKGROUND. AB EIGHT EIGHTEEN
TWELVE IN JUNE OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN MANDATED POST CREATED
INNOVATIONS GRANT PROGRAM. WHERE
I. G. P. IN HOPES OF REDUCING
OFFICER INVOLVED SHOOTINGS. AS
PART OF THE IGP. POST WAS
DIRECTED TO DISTRIBUTE FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN FOR THREE
YEAR. TIME PERIODS IN TRAINING.
GRANTS TO COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS. LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES AND OTHER ENTITIES. ONE
OF THE FIVE TOPIC AREAS. ARE
DEFINED IN AB EIGHTEEN TWELVE
WITH PEACE OFFICER WELLNESS.
PUTS COMPLETED THREE SEPARATE
ROUNDS OF I. G. P. FUNDING OVER
TWO YEAR TIME PERIOD. AS A
RESULT A TOTAL OF TEN GRANTS
TOTALING. ONE POINT TWO MILLION
DOLLARS WERE ISSUED FOR PEACE
ALSO WANNA STRAINING. THE TOTAL
FOUR HUNDRED SEVENTY ONE
STUDENTS RECEIVE WANNA
STRAINING. FINALLY G. P. GRANTS
EXPIRED. ON DECEMBER THIRTY ONE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. DURING THE
INITIAL MONTHS A COUPLE OF THE
COVERT PANDEMIC. COSTA A PCP IN
THE SPRING OF TWENTY TWENTY FOR
AN ONLINE TRAINING PROGRAM TO.
THE FIVE TOPIC REQUIREMENTS IN
AB EIGHTEEN TWELVE. PROGRAM WE
CALL THE DISTANCE LEARNING GRANT
PROGRAM WE'RE DEAL G. P. ACP WAS
SUBMITTED IN AS MUCH AS A CAR AS
CLASSROOM BASED TRAINING WAS ALL
BUT ELIMINATED IN THE ENTIRETY
OF TWENTY TWENTY. BCP WAS
APPROVED AND FUNDING WAS
INCORPORATED INTO THE TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET
ACT. RECIPIENTS WERE LIMITED TO
LAW ENFORCEMENT DEPARTMENTS IN
ACADEMIA. PART OF THE DEAL G. P.
CASAS GRANDES FORTY TO
DISTRIBUTE FIVE MILLION FOR THE
FIVE TOPIC AREAS ONE OF WHICH
BEING WELLNESS AS A RESULT TOTAL
FOR WELLNESS GRANTS TOTALING.
NINE HUNDRED THIRTY SEVEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS WERE ISSUED A
TOTAL OF SEVEN HUNDRED NINETY
EIGHT STUDENTS RECEIVED ONLINE
WHILE THE STREET. THE FINAL
DETAIL GPRS EXPIRED ON DECEMBER
THIRTY ONE TWENTY TWENTY ONE. IN
JUNE OF TWENTY TWENTY WE
RELEASED A PSA STYLE VIDEO ON
WELLNESS CALLED SILENT NO MORE.
AS WELL AS A TWO HOUR CLASSROOM
BASED FACILITATES FACILITATED
TRAINING VIDEO. WE ARE SCHEDULED
TO HOLD A WORKSHOP TO CREATE
MANDATED BASIC ECONOMY
CURRICULUM ON WELLNESS IN LATE
OF LATE MARCH TWENTY TWENTY.
UNFORTUNATELY WE ARE FORCED TO
CANCEL THE WORKSHOP TO COME OF
IT. WE'RE NOW TENTATIVELY
SCHEDULED TO START UP AGAIN WITH
THE WORKSHOP IN MAY. SIMILARLY
FOR THE LAST SIX MONTHS WE'VE
BEEN REVAMPING THE DISPATCHER
BASIC TRAINING COURSE. THE NEW
BASIC TRAINING WHICH IS MANDATED
FOR ALL DISPATCHERS WILL INCLUDE
STANDARD CURRICULUM ON
DISPATCHER WELLNESS. WE HOPE TO
HAVE A DISPATCHER- BASICALLY HE
ON COMPLETED BY THE END OF THIS
YEAR WITH THE POINT SOMETIME IN
TWENTY TWENTY THREE. STARTING A
WELLNESS DISCUSSION AT THE
BEGINNING OF A LAW ENFORCEMENT
PROFESSIONALS CAREERS AN
IMPORTANT EARLY STEP FOR THE
INDIVIDUAL THE DEPARTMENT AND
THEIR COMMUNITY. SUFFICE IT TO
SAY FOR THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS
WE'VE BEEN FOCUSED ON TRAINING
DELIVERY. THEREFORE THIS VCP
SHIFTS THE PRIMARY FOCUS TO
DEPARTMENT SPECIFIC WELLNESS
WORKSHOPS. EACH DEPARTMENT IS
DIFFERENT IN TERMS OF THE
WELLNESS ISSUES THEY FACE. SOME
MAY FACE HIGH ON DUTY INJURIES
SUICIDES LACK OF EFFECTIVE PEER
SUPPORT IT CETERA ETCETERA. EACH
DEPARTMENT IS DIFFERENT THUS THE
DELIVERABLES OBJECTIVE
OBJECTIVES AND OUTCOMES FOR EACH
DEPARTMENT MUST BE TAILORED.
HOUSE DESIRES TO PARTNER WITH
ACADEMIA CLINICIANS AND EXPERTS
IN THE AREA OF WELLNESS TO WORK
WITH INDIVIDUAL LINE FOR STATE
DEPARTMENTS TO CREATE OR IMPROVE
HAVE. BY LEVERAGING THE
PARTNERSHIPS WITH ACADEMIA
CLINICIANS IN THE EXPERTS CLOSE
WILL EVALUATE THE ISSUES THE
DELIVERABLES THE FOLLOW THROUGH
AND THE OUTCOMES FOR EACH
DEPARTMENT PROJECT. WE ARE
CONFIDENT LAW ENFORCEMENT
PROFESSIONALS WERE EMOTIONALLY
AND PHYSICALLY HEALTHY NOT ONLY
HELP THEMSELVES IN THEIR
DEPARTMENT. BUT BUT OUR IS
BETTER SERVICE TO THEIR
COMMUNITY. STUDIES HAVE
DEMONSTRATED THAT TO BE TRUE AND
WE CAN GO INTO SOME OF THOSE
STUDIES IF YOU'D LIKE. THEREFORE
THIS B. C. P. ADDRESSES THE
CONTINUE DELIVERY OF TRAINING.
PERMITS THE STATE A LEADERSHIP
ROLE TO WORK WITH INDIVIDUAL
DEPARTMENTS. TO FURTHER THEIR
INDIVIDUAL WELLNESS JACKETS.
THAT MADAM CHAIR WE THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING US TO TESTIFY TO
YOUR COMMITTEE WE STAND READY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU MISTER OVER IS-
WITH FINANCE LIKE TO MAKE ANY
COMMENTS. YES MANAGER ANYTHING
FRIENDS OR CORPORATE FINANCE
AGAIN- AGAIN TO PRACTICE SOME OF
THE L. A. AS CONCERNS THAT MISS
PETERS WILL SPEAK TO THE
MINISTRATION BELIEVES HE
PROPOSED PROGRAM HAS VERY
SPECIFIC GOALS WHICH INCLUDE
SUPPORTING LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES BUILDING THEIR CAPACITY
TO OFFER BOTH INDIVIDUAL LEVEL
AN ORGANIZATIONAL. WELLNESS
PROGRAMMING- ONE OF THE PRIMARY
WAYS POST WILL DO THIS IS BY
HOSTING AGENCY BONUS WORKSHOPS
OVER THREE CONSECUTIVE FISCAL
YEARS- IN ADDITION TO YOU
ABSOLUTELY SOLICITING THE
CREATION OF WELLNESS RELATED
RESOURCES AND MULTIMEDIA
AGGREGATED AND DISSEMINATING
BEST PRACTICES FOR WELLNESS AND
WORKING WITH PARTNERS IN
ACADEMIA TO EVALUATE- OR DID YOU
VALUATIONS THAT CAN SUPPORT THE
IDENTIFICATION OF BEST
PRACTICES. WE BELIEVE POST IS
UNIQUELY POSITIONED AND ASKING
SITE INTO LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCY OPERATIONS AND THE EXTENT
TO WHICH WELL THIS IS HANDLED
WITHIN THOSE AGENCIES AND AS
DIRECTOR ALVAREZ NOBODY KNOWS
HOW TO IDENTFY THAT THERE IS A
SIGNIFICANT GAP AMONG AGENCIES
PERTAINS TO OFFEREE AGAIN THIS
INDIVIDUAL AND ORGANIZATIONAL
WELLNESS PROGRAMMING AND THAT'S
WHAT THIS. PROGRAM IS INTENDED
TO ADDRESS- MINISTRY I'VE ALSO
NOTED IS HAPPY TO PROVIDE I DO
INFORMATION JUST. TO THE L. A.
AND ALLEGE. NECESSARY HOWEVER
THE INTENT IS TO GIVE POST THE
FLEXIBILITY IN DELIVERING THIS
PROGRAM DUE TO THE KIND OF A
WIDE VARIETY OF. SIZE AND
CAPACITY- GEOGRAPHIC NEEDS UP TO
ONE COURSE AGENCIES ACROSS THE
STATE. AND I WOULD LAST WE KNOW
IN THIS TIES INTO YOU ARE THE
PREVIOUS PROPOSAL WITH SB TWO BY
THE L. A. R. TO CONCERNED ABOUT
IMPLEMENTATION AS IT RELATES TO
KIND OF DOING THIS PROGRAM. SB
TWO AT THE SAME TIME AGAIN WE
BELIEVE POETAS OF STANGEL
EXPERIENCED IN THIS TYPE OF
PROGRAM DELIVERY AGAIN A STRONG
RECORD OFFERS A SPOKEN TO-
ENABLE ALSO BE DIFFERENT STAFF
WHO WERE WORKING ON A SPEECH YOU
IN DIFFERENT STAFF WERE WORKING.
OFFICER WELL SO ALTHOUGH SB TWO
APPLICATIONS CRITICAL AND THAT
WILL BE A CENTRAL FOCUS- POST
DOES HAVE THE CAPACITY AND THE
ABILITY TO WORK UP THE SAME TIME
AND I'LL CONCLUDE. MY COMMENTS
THANK YOU. HANK YOU VERY MUCH-
WE TURN TO OUR L. A- PLEASE.
SPEAKING MEDICARE DISTRIBUTORS
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE AGAIN SH SO I THINK THE
WE THINK THE OVERALL CONCEPT AS
FOCUSING ON OFFICER WELLNESS HAS
MERIT- OFFICER WELLNESS IS
IMPORTANT AND IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
OFFICERS TO BE ABLE TO
EFFECTIVELY. ADMINISTER THEIR
DUTIES AND DE ESCALATE DANGEROUS
SITUATION SENSE OF THE OVERALL
CONCEPT HAS NEAR H. AND HOWEVER
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL AND THAT
DOESN'T INCLUDE SOME OF THE
DETAILS THAT WE WOULD AYE THAT
TYPICALLY I LIKE TO SEE IT FOR A
PROPOSAL THAT COULD REALLY
DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT THE
PROPOSED PROGRAM WOULD ACTUALLY
IMPROVE OFFICER WELLNESS. AND IN
PARTICULAR WE FIND THAT THERE'S
A NUMBER OF UNANSWERED QUESTIONS
REGARDING THE PROPOSAL. AND AS
WAS MENTIONED THERE IS A VARIETY
OF ACTIVITIES THAT WOULD BE
UNDERTAKEN THE PROPOSAL DOES NOT
AND IDENTIFY. HOW MUCH FUNDING
WOULD BE ALLOCATED TO THE
DIFFERENT ACTIVITIES- NEED
SPECIFIC PRIMARY GOALS OF THE
PROGRAM ARE NOT IDENTIFIED AS
WAS ALLUDED TO THERE IS A HIGH
LEVEL GOALS IN TERMS OF
IMPROVING INDIVIDUAL OFFICER
WELLNESS IMPROVING
ORGANIZATIONAL WELLNESS FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES AND EVEN
I'M IMPROVING I'M COMMUNITY
WHILE LAST OUT WITH REGARDS TO
LAW ENFORCEMENT- AND WHILE ALL
OF THOSE ARE IMPORTANT. AND THAT
WITHOUT A SPECIFIC ASSESSMENT
OF. WHAT GOALS WOULD BE TARGETED
WITH THE SCIENCES DIFFICULT FOR
THE LEGISLATURE TO EVALUATE THE
MERITS OF THE PROGRAM- IN
ADDITION WE FIND THAT
ADMINISTRATION HAS NOT ANSWERED
THE QUESTION- SPECIFICALLY IN
TERMS OF THE PROBLEMS THAT WOULD
BE SOLVED. WITH THESE FINE SIDE
THERE HAS NOT BEEN AN ASSESSMENT
OF SPECIFIC GAPS OR WEAKNESSES
IN EXISTING LINE FIRST MEANT
WELLNESS PROGRAMS- AND WHAT
SHOULD BE IMPORTANT. FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO NOW IN TERMS OF
HOW THESE WERE ACT. MAYBE
ALLOCATED TO SPECIFIC ACTIVE AND
WHETHER THE DUST ACT- OR THE
MOST AFFECT ONES CHU I THE- AND
- RIGHT- AGAIN I ALSO DOES NOT
IDENTIFY THIS ACTIVITIES THAT
WOULD BE FUNDED AND WE CAN
SUPPORT FOR THE LEAD. TO KNOW
APPROVING ANY FOR I AND ITS
BANKS WHAT WOULD BE EXPECTED
WITH THE SPARTANS I'M SUCH AS A
MEASURABLE METRICS ON
IMPROVEMENT IN OFFICER WELLNESS
OR EVEN THE NUMBER OF OFFICERS
THAT WOULD BE SERVICE THROUGH
THESE PROGRAMS- I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO KNOW HOW THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS INDICATED
THAT- WELL THE PROPOSAL DOESN'T
SAY IT'S LIKELY THAT POST WHICH
USED TO PROVIDE A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF THE SPENDING INTO THE
OFFICER WELLNESS WORKSHOPS THAT
IT PLANS TO DEMOLISH. I OUR
OFFICE IS BEEN TOLD THAT I HAD
THIS LEVEL OF FUNDING COULD
SUPPORT ROUGHLY THIRTY FIVE OF
THESE OFFICER WELLNESS WORKSHOPS
AT THIRTY FIVE ONE PERSON
AGENCIES WITH OVER SIX HUNDRED A
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES IN THE
STATE- UNDERSTANDING THOSE
OUTCOMES AND HOW FUNDS WILL BE
ALLOCATED IS IMPORTANT SINCE
OBVIOUSLY THIS WOULD NOT PROVIDE
ENOUGH FUNDING FOR THIRTY FIVE
WORKSHOPS TO COVER ALL SIX
HUNDRED. LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES IN THE STATE- AND TO
THE EXTENT HOUSE HAS A PLAN TO
DO THAT UNDERSTANDING THE
DETAILS OF THAT WOULD BE
IMPORTANT FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
GET A SENSE AS TO HOW MANY
OFFICERS WOULD BE SERVED THROUGH
THE PROGRAM. AND IN TERMS AS-
THIS. THIS PER WE HAVE BEEN THAT
COSTA IT WILL TAKE ROUGHLY A- TO
DEVOUR THE- OF THIS CAR. AND PER
I HAD TO TAPES OF THE THAT WE
THINK LEGISLATURE I WOULD WANT
TO KNOW BEFORE APPROVING
SPENDING- AND IF. IF IT WOULD
TAKE THAT LONG TO DEVELOP THE
PROGRAM SHE DOES RAISE A
QUESTION ABOUT TO WHAT EXTENT
SHOULD HAVE HOST COULD HANDLE
DEVELOPING THIS NEW PROGRAM AT
THE SAME TIME THAT THEY ARE
ROLLING OUT THE VERY SIGNIFICANT
EFFORTS TO. IMPLEMENT SB TO
WHICH AS WHAT IS SPOKEN TO
EARLIER OR MIGHT IT MINISTRATION
IS REQUIRING REDIRECTING SOME OF
THE EXISTING STOCK OF OTHER AN
EXISTING PROGRAMS. TO THAT
EFFORT AND SO JUST GIVEN THE
MAGNITUDE OF ASK YOU TO
IMPLEMENTATION AS WELL AS. THIS
PROPOSAL NOT. DURING A HERE TO
BE TO. WE CAN THAT REYES ACROSS
FOR THE JUST A IN TERMS OF. HOW
THEY TO MIGHT FACTORY ANOTHER-
SO IN TERMS OF OUR- WE WOULDN'T
THAT YOU DIRECT CLOSE TO PROVIDE
A GREATER LEVEL OF DETAIL AND
MARK PERMISSION TO ANSWER THESE
KEY QUESTIONS THAT WE'VE
IDENTIFIED. TO THE EXTENT THAT
YOU RECEIVE INFORMATION THAT YOU
FELT JUSTIFIES THE PROGRAM HAND
CAN SUPPORT THE LEGISLATURE
SCHOOLS FOR OFFICER WELLNESS OUT
THEN WE WOULD RECOMMEND YOU
APPROVE THE PROPOSAL. TO THE
EXTENT THAT TIME IT DOES TAKE
HOST A LONGER AMOUNT OF TIME AS
WELL AS I NATIONALLY INDICATED
TO OUR OFFICE TO PROVIDE THOSE
DETAILS OF THEIR UNABLE TO
PROVIDE THEM FOR THE DETAILS
DON'T. ON ADEQUATELY ALIGNED
WITH THE LEGISLATURE SCHOOLS-
AND THEN WE WOULD RECOMMEND THAT
YOU REJECT THE PROGRAM WITHOUT
PREJUDICE. SO THAT HOST HAS MORE
TIME TO DEVELOP THE PROGRAM I
COULD BRING A PROPOSAL FORWARD I
CAN THE NEXT BUDGET YEAR AND I'M. HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS
PETERS- APPRECIATE THAT CALL AND
- QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS EVAN. NO
OKAY GREAT WELL- MISTER LEWIS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- FOR YOU AND
YOUR DEPARTMENT. THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT AS- SOME WAYS JUST AS
IMPORTANT AS SB TWO IN A
DIFFERENT WAY IT ARE REALLY
IMPORTANT- THAT WE MOVE FOR WITH
THE RESOURCES THAT ARE NEEDED
FOR. THE WELLNESS OF OUR
OFFICERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
SO. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR ALL
THAT YOU'RE DOING AND- OBVIOUSLY
THERE IS ISSUES RAISED BY THE
LA- THAT WE ARE- YOU KNOW-
SUPPORTIVE OF. AND LOOK FORWARD
TO MORE INFORMATION IN THE
FUTURE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
EVERYONE WE'RE MOVING ON NOW TO-
ISSUE THIRTEEN I THINK IT'S OUR
LAST ISSUE. BEFORE WE GO TO
PUBLIC COMMENTS SO- THIS IS A
SUPPORT THE GENERAL WORKLOAD FOR
THE OFFICE OF THE STATE PUBLIC
DEFENDER. AND AGAIN- LET'S SEE
WHO WILL BE PRESENTING ON BEHALF
OF POST. MADAM CHAIRMAN I'M
AMEREN COLEMAN THE STATE PUBLIC
DEFENDER FROM THE OFFICE OF THE
STATE PUBLIC DEFENDER. AND
MYSELF AND MY COLLEAGUE KELLY
PUBLICLY PRESENTING ON BEHALF OF
THE STATE PUBLIC OFFICE OF THE
STATE PUBLIC DEFENDER. OKAY-
THANK YOU- THANKS THANK YOU-
MADAM CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE
PEOPLE FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS THIS COMMITTEE- IN
TWENTY TWENTY IN THE LEGISLATURE
EXPANDED THE MISSION OF THE
OFFICE OF THE STATE PUBLIC
DEFENDER. TO RECRUIT TRAINING
INTENSE TECHNICAL SUPPORT FOR
THOSE. PEOPLE REPRESENTING
INDIGENT DEFENDANTS ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. PURPOSE
ABOUT MANDATE WAS TO IMPROVE
PUBLIC DEFENSE IN CALIFORNIA. O.
S. P. G. CREATED THE INDIGENT
DEFENSE IMPROVEMENT DIVISION ID
ID. ABOUT MANDATE AND WITHOUT I
WILL PASS OUR PRESENTATION TO MY
COLLEAGUE GOLLY THE BOX WHO IS
THE NEW EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
THE INDIGENT DEFENSE IMPROVEMENT
DIVISION AND SHE WILL DESCRIBE
IDEA IDEA AND SOME OF ITS RECENT
EFFORTS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. HELLO I AM VERY SAD
MY NAME IS THE LEAD LATE I AM
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
INDIGENT DEFENSE IMPROVEMENT
DIVISION THANK YOU FOR GIVING US
A COUPLE MINUTES TO TALK ABOUT
OUR WORK IN UPDATES ON THE
PUBLIC DEFENSE I KNOW EVERYONE
IS EAGER TO MOVE ON SO I'LL BE
QUICK AND WE ARE A NEW DIVISION
VERY SAD OUR GOAL IS ULTIMATELY
TO ENSURE THAT EVERY CALIFORNIA
AND REGARDLESS OF WHERE THEY
LIVE OR HOW MUCH MONEY THEY HAVE
THE HAS COMPLETE ACCESS TO THEIR
CONSTITUTIONAL. AND STATUTORY
RIGHTS AND A FAIR CHANCE OF
JUSTICE IN OUR LEGAL SYSTEM AND
IT'S AN EXCITING BUT CHALLENGING
MANDATE CALIFORNIA DOES NOT HAVE
WON THE INDIGENT DEFENSE SYSTEM
THAT WE CAN FOCUS ON BUT RATHER
FIFTY EIGHT ENTIRELY UNIQUE
SYSTEMS BECAUSE IN CALIFORNIA
EACH COUNTY HAS ALL
RESPONSIBILITY OF DESIGNING AN
ENTIRELY FINDING ITS OWN SYSTEM
FOR ENSURING THAT POOR PEOPLE
ACCUSED OF CRIMES RECEIVE
QUALITY ASSISTANCE OF COUNSEL
I'M SO CALIFORNIA THE HUGE
DISPARITY IN THE QUALITY OF
INDIGENT DEFENSE SERVICES BY
PEOPLE IN NEED RECEIVED IN FACT
WE HAVE TWENTY FIVE COUNTIES
WITH NO PUBLIC DEFENDER OFFICES
AT ALL SHE ADDED DISPARITIES
ONLY INCREASED WITH COVERT
BACKLOGS AND TWENTY BUDGETS
BEING STRETCHED. SO WELCOME
AFRICAN ADDRESSING SOME OF THE
NEED CAME LAST FISCAL YEAR IN
THE FORM OF THE PUBLIC DEFENSE
HIGHLIGHT WITH THE FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLAR GRANT PROGRAM
WHICH WAS DESIGNED TO SUPPORT
CERTAIN POST CONVICTION WORK AT
YES YOU SEE WAS HALF GRANTED OUT
THOSE PLANS WHEN I'M IN MY NEW
DIVISION AND- SPD PLAYING A
CONSULTING ROLE AT BECAUSE
CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF THE FEW
STATES THAT DOESN'T PROVIDE
REGULAR. FUNDING FOR INDIGENT
DEFENSE. SHORTY OF. DEFENSE FROM
THIS THE FIRST TIME THEY EVER.
STATE FUNDING. AND THE FIRST
TIME THEY ARE. FOR A- ANY. SO
ONE OF THE EARLY TWO. THAT THIS
GRANT PROGRAM. WITH THAT YES SEE
NOT HAVE A- WITH INDIGENT
DEFENSE. AND THIS. DID NOT HAVE
A WITH RAP. SHE SO AS A RESULT
I'M- MY- DIVISION I TOOK A SOME
OF THE- LIFTING AND IT OF THE
MEETING OUT OF REACH THE GRAPH.
WE DID. WEBINARS ASSEMBLY THE
APPLE. OPEN ABOUT THE FROM AND
THE PROCESS TRYING TO REACH
INDIGENT DEFENSE PROVIDERS IN
EVERY COUNTY TO ALERT THEM OF
THE OPPORTUNITY. AND GIVE THEM
THE CHANCE TO START THINKING
ABOUT HOW THEY WOULD DESIGN
THEIR FUNDING. AND THE GRANT
APPLICATION. HOW DO WITHOUT
DEFENDER. WERE PRETTY HARD TO
REACH AND ULTIMATELY APPLIED IN
MUCH SMALLER NUMBERS. BUT WE
RECEIVED FEEDBACK THAT ALL SPD
SEMINARS ARE A WARM VITALLY
IMPORTANT IN GETTING PEOPLE TO
APPLY. APPLICATION PROCESS
OPENED. AGAIN OUR DIVISION
OFFERS YES ON SUPPORT TO
INDIGENT DEFENSE PROVIDERS IN
THE GRANT PROCESS WHILE WE DID
WORK CONSISTENTLY WITH THE BIG
OFFICES BUT THE BIG COUNTIES. I
SPENT MOST OF MY TIME WITH SMALL
OR RURAL CHINESE WHERE THE
RESOURCES ARE PARTICULARLY
STRETCHED AND INDIGENT DEFENSE
PROVIDERS FELT OVERWHELMED BY
THE BSP SEEK PROCESS. BUT OF
COURSE WE WANTED TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY WERE SO OVERWHELMED BY
THE FCC PROCESS THAT THEY DIDN'T
APPLY FOR THE FUN. WE ALSO WORK
WITH THE SEC HAN RANT AND
EVALUATIONS. BRINGING OUR
EXPERTISE ON INDIGENT DEFENSE
SYSTEM. WHAT WE LEARNED IN THIS
PROCESS IS THAT THE STANDARD
PSEC MODEL OF JUST PUTTING UP A
NOTICE ON THE WEBSITE AND
SENDING OUT A MASS EMAIL AND
SEEN WHAT PRIZE BY THE DEADLINE.
DOES NOT WORK FOR INDIGENT
DEFENSE GRANTS TO ENSURE EQUITY
ACROSS THE STATE THESE GRANT
PROGRAMS REQUIRE. AND
RELATIONSHIP BUILDING AND
UNDERSTANDING OF THE
COMPLEXITIES OF THE SUBJECT
MATTER AND MEANINGFUL HANDS. ON
ASSISTANCE TO THESE PROVIDERS.
I'M IT MY DIVISION WAS PRETTY
BOTH FOR THIS WORK AND WE REALLY
LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING FUTURE
OPPORTUNITIES. TO BUILD ON WHAT
WE LEARNED AND I'M ON THIS
PROCESS. I AM PROUD TO REPORT
THAT OF THE FORTY NINE AND A
HALF MILLION THAT WAS AVAILABLE
TO BE ALLOCATED OVER FORTY SEVEN
MILLION HAVE BEEN APPLIED FOR.
I'M WE DO SEE ALWAYS SPEEDY DOES
SEE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR AT LEAST
ANOTHER MILLION TO BE APPLIED
FOR AND WE'VE ASKED THE SEC TO
RE OPEN APPLICATION PERIOD FOR
THAT PURPOSE. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK. WITH
INDIGENT DEFENSE PROVIDERS AS
THEY START GETTING THEIR FUNDING
HOPEFULLY IN MARCH ADD TO THE
INDIGENT DEFENSE IMPROVEMENT
DIVISION IS PLANNING A SERIES OF
TRAINING FOR THE NEW STAFF
BACKED OUT. WILL BE HIRED WITH
THIS GRANT FUNDING. I'LL JUST
SAY THAT IN A TO WORK ON THE
GRANT PROGRAM CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE FREE HIGH QUALITY
TRAININGS ON CHANGES TO THE LAW.
IMPORTANT ISSUES IN PUBLIC THE
FUNDS ON THE HELP OFFICERS
ENGAGED IN SYSTEMIC CHANGE WE
ALSO REALLY OF ANY DIVISION LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO FIND
WAYS TO INFORM THIS LEGISLATURE
AND THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA.
ABOUT THE HEALTH OF THEIR
VITALLY IMPORTANT PUBLIC DEFENSE
SYSTEMS AND WE'RE ALWAYS
AVAILABLE. TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
ABOUT THESE IMPORTANT ISSUES. I
WILL LEAVE. IT AT THAT AND I'M
THINKING. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR WE MOVE ON TO A COMMENT OF.
FINANCE DO YOU HAVE ANY OF
SHORT. COMMENTS YES I'M ACTUALLY
JUST WANTED TO. SPEAK TO WHAT'S
INCLUDED IN THE BUDGET SO THE
BUDGET INCLUDES FOUR HUNDRED
FORTY TWO THOUSAND ONGOING
GENERAL FUND AND GREENHOUSE THE
SHOTS FOR THE STATE PUBLIC
DEFENDER. TO ADDRESS OUR
WORKLOAD RELATED TO HUMAN
RESOURCES BUDGET SERVICES AND
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY. ARE
THESE ADDITIONAL POSITIONS WILL
ALLOW THE STATE PUBLIC DEFENDER
TO POPULOUS AS COLORED STATUTORY
RESPONSIBILITIES SINCE THE
PROVIDE. TRAINING AND TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO LOCAL VENDORS
FROM. PRESENT INDIGENT
INDIVIDUALS ACROSS THE STATE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THAT'S WHAT'S BEFORE US TODAY.
A. O. ANY COMMENTS. ANY DALY AT
THE A. R. NO. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR THANK YOU VERY MUCH
CALLING. ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS NO. OKAY GOOD SO WE
WILL NOW THANK YOU EVERYONE-
MISTER COLEMAN AND OTHERS FROM
THE DEPARTMENT PRE SHAPED VERY
MUCH. WE WILL NOW MOVE ON. TO
ANYONE WANTING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT REGARDING ANY OF THE
ISSUES DISCUSSED TODAY AS A
REMINDER TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO
NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS THREE FIVE
THREE ONE TWO EIGHT THREE. DUE
TO CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS. WE WILL- INSTITUTE A
TIME LIMITS ON TESTIMONY- TODAY
DEPENDING ON HOW MANY WE HAVE IN
QUEUE. OF MODERATOR WOULD YOU BE
ABLE TO. PROMPT INDIVIDUALS
WILLING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT AND LET US KNOW HOW MANY
INDIVIDUALS ARE WAITING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT. I'M
SORRY WE NEED TO BEGIN WITH ANY
WITNESSES HERE IN THE ROOM. SEEN
NONE- AS THE MODERATOR TO PROMPT
THOSE WAITING- AND IF YOU WOULD
LET US KNOW HOW MANY INDIVIDUALS
ARE WAITING. THANK YOU- AS OF
RIGHT NOW BEFORE GIFT STRUCTURES
WE ALREADY HAVE FOUR CUED UP ON
FOR EVERYBODY ELSE IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO. MAKE PUBLIC COMMENT ON
ANY OF THESE- ITEMS PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY THE ZERO DOWN AT
T. OPERATORS GOING TO GIVE YOUR
LINE NUMBER OFFLINE IN THE
QUICKLY PLACE YOUR RIGHT ACK IN
THE QUEUE. AGAIN FOR OUR PUBLIC
COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND WE WILL GO TO
START I'M SORRY MODERATOR I'M
SORRY COULD YOU TELL ME AGAIN
HOW MANY ARE WAITING. RIGHT NOW
YOU ARE AT TEN. OKAY A REALLY
ASK EVERYONE TO GIVE A- GIVE
EVERYONE A CHANCE TO- SAY
SOMETHING PLEASE INTRODUCE
YOURSELVES YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND- THE ISSUE THAT
YOU ARE CALLING IN FOR YOU KNOW
YOU SUPPORTED YOU DON'T- BECAUSE
WE NEED TO HAVE EVERYONE- SPEAK
. THANK YOU. SOMEONE ONE GOAL IS
TO OUTLINE FIFTEEN YOU ARE OPEN. FIFTEEN CAN YOU HEAR US PLEASE
ON MUTE. I CAN INDICATING. CAN
THAT. BRENDAN GREENE HI
DEREGULATION ECONOMIC JUSTICE
PROGRAM AT A CELLULAR NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. ALL THE WILL REGARD
TO I DON'T WANT. IT WILL AFFECT
ME. AND I JUST WANTED TO SAY A
COUPLE OF THINGS ONE WE ARE. BY
THE ADMINISTRATION FOR PUTTING
FORTH A PROPOSAL TO CUT THE DEAL
WITH THAT YOU CAN ADD- PROVIDER
WE WANT WE THINK COULD GROW
PROPOSAL DOES NOT GO FAR ENOUGH.
TO LOOK AT WE SHOULD BE
ELIMINATED IN THEIR ENTIRETY I
THANK YOU FOR VARIETY OF
REASONS- ONE IN TERMS OF AN
ACCOUNTABILITY MECHANISM ONE
ALREADY EXISTS- THAT A TRIAL
DATE THANK YOU DON'T SHOW UP TO
COURT- YOU CAN BE FOUND. GUILTY
ON THE PAPERS SO WE'RE MOVING TO
LOOK AT NICK THAT THE COUNTY
WOULD NOT REMOVE ACCOUNTABILITY.
BACK THE WE KNOW TO BE TO THE
RIGHT TO GET THE- ISSUE- AS ALL
DATA RELATED TO TRAFFIC STOP TO
SHOW THAT A DISPROPORTIONATE
IMPACT BLACK FOLKS REPHAIM.
WORKLOAD DATA SHOWED FOR EXAMPLE
THAT NOT ONLY A BLACK FOLKS
PULLED OVER DISPROPORTIONATE
RATE THEY'RE TAKING
DISPROPORTIONATE RATES HAVE TO
BE CLOSER DISPROPORTIONATE RIGHT
HANDER HOW MAY ALL CORRELATE
WITH ALL THE DATA THAT WE KNOW
ABOUT. DRIVERS LIKE INTERFACE
PAYER AND FAIR TO PAY- EXACTLY A
MANIFESTATION OF RACIALIZED
POLICING BISCAYNE CERTAINLY.
RACIALIZED WELL STRIPPING. WE
ALSO KNOW THAT PEOPLE AREN'T
SHOWING SHOWING UP THE COURT
BECAUSE THEY DON'T WANT TO.
ADDING A HUNDRED DOLLAR CAN.
PARTNERSHIP YEAH PENALTY WHAT
HAPPENED TRACK TO GET THAT
ALREADY LOOKING. IN THE- IT'S
NOT ACTUALLY ADDING TO PROGRESS
UP TO THE OUR HAD A FOR TO PAY
THE BRAKES AND TAKING. AND WE
KNOW THAT. YEAH THEY'RE QUITE
ARE WE ABOUT- BE IMPACTING-
LEVINE YOU KNOW WHEN PEOPLE GET
PAYING. RIGHT THEY DON'T SHOW UP
YEAH I'M I'M SO- GONE BY. FACT
UP THIS TIME HERE WE WANT MOVE
ON TO THE NEXT GIVE OTHER THE-
PLEASE- JEFF SAY YOUR NAME. F.
YOUR PHILLY WITH AN ORGAN. THE
ISSUE WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH TIME
TO- GO DEEPER INTO YOUR
TESTIMONY BUT- WE WANT TO GIVE
EVERYBODY OPPORTUNITIES OF
PLEASE LESS THAN THIRTY SECONDS-
SO THAT WE CAN- AND THIS ON
TIME. NEXT UP MODERATOR. FIND
THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS JUST. A SINGLE LINE
THIRTY FIVE YOUR OPEN. WHEN WE
CALL YOUR NAME THAT MAJOR LINER
YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU ARE OPEN.
THIRTY FIVE. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME'S RIOS ARE FROM A- ATTORNEY
AT THE LAWYERS COMMITTEE FOR
CIVIL RIGHTS TO THE TAMPA BAY
AREA- HERE TO ENCOURAGE YOU TO
ELIMINATE THE TABLE AT THE
AFTERMATH WE APPLAUD THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR PROPOSING A
REDUCTION TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
DOLLARS BUT IT IS NOT SUFFICIENT
PEOPLE ARE STRUGGLING WITH THE
THREE HUNDRED DOLLARS AND THEY
WILL CONTINUE TO STRUGGLE WITH
THE HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS- THE
LAST THING I WANT TO SAY IS JUST
THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
DID NOT ADDRESS. SENATOR GERAGOS
QUESTION ABOUT DEBT RELIEF IT IS
CRITICAL THAT ANY REFORM TO THE
CIVIL ATTACHMENT ALSO INCLUDE
RETROACTIVE DEBT RELIEF THANK
WHAT HAPPENED ARE HARMING PEOPLE
THERE ARE FAILED TOOL OF
ACCOUNTABILITY AND THEY POSE A
HUGE CONFLICT OF INTEREST
ELIMINATE THEM ENTIRELY AND MANY
OF THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
RIGHTFULLY THE JACK. THAT THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT.
NINE THIRTY FOUR YOU ARE OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS KELLY
WILDERNESS STAFF ATTORNEY WITH
LEGAL SERVICES FOR PRISONERS
WITH CHILDREN I AM ALSO CALLING
REGARDING ISSUE ONE- I ALSO
WOULD APPLY AND BE
ADMINISTRATION OR REDUCING THE
AMOUNT OF SURPLUS ASPECTS
HOWEVER. AS LONG AS THE PEOPLE
BEFORE ME STATED THAT DOES NOT
GO FAR ENOUGH IT IS SIMPLY
INEXCUSABLE TO PUT PEOPLE INTO
DEBT AND THE WAY THAT THE
CALIFORNIA COURTS HAVE DONE SO
FURTHERMORE A LOT. OF ALL THAT
IN DOING SO- THE CORTEX
PENALIZING POVERTY AND-
EXPECTING BE AT THE BLACK AND
BROWN PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA TO
BEAR THE BRUNT OF THESE
ACCOMPLISHMENTS WHICH CAN. THANK
YOU ROBERT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
HELP TO GET UP TO EIGHT POINT
FIVE TIMES WHAT IT ORIGINALLY
WAS. THANK YOU VERY MAKING NEXT
. FIVE THIRTY YOUR OPEN TO GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
GARCIA THE POLICY NOW EITHER FOR
YOU THE LIVE WE ARE A VICTIM
ORGANIZATION BASED OUT IN
CALIFORNIA AND PART OF OUR WORK
IS SERVING VICTIMS OF VIOLENT
CRIME. AT WORK WE HAVE LEARNED
ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA VICTIM
COMPENSATION EXPENSE HAD STRICT
ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA THAT
PREVENTED MANY SURVIVORS FROM
GETTING BACK THAT HUMAN
RESOURCES THAT THEY NEED IN
ORDER TO RECOVER FROM SURVIVING
OR LOSING A LOVED ONE FOR
VIOLENT INCIDENT. SO WE WOULD
REALLY APPRECIATE YOU MAY BE
LOOKING AT THE BUDGET FOR THE
PROGRAM MAKING SURE THAT WE CAN
EXPAND ELIGIBILITY FOR THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT IS NO LONGER
DETERMINING WHO IS A DESERVING.
THANK. YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH
NEXT. PIXELBOOK A LINE THIRTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME'S
TIM OF THE JUSTICE JOBS
COALITION FALLS APART OF THE
CARE FIRST CALIFORNIA COALITION-
LAST YEAR- WE STOOD AGAINST THE-
HUNDRED FORTY MILLION DOLLARS
AND- INVESTMENT INTO PROPANE TO
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL'S-
PROBATION AND PRETRIAL SYSTEM
WHICH WE CONSIDER. RACIST AND-
AND BIASED. WE JUST WANT TO
ALERT YOU AGAIN TOO AGAIN THE
BASE FUNDING I THINK IT'S
SEVENTY MILLION THIS YEAR AGAIN
THAT'S GOING INTO PROBATION- AND
WE ARE DEEPLY CONCERNED ABOUT
THAT AND DESPITE ANY-
INVESTMENTS IN STATEWIDE DATA
MANAGEMENT PLATFORM WHICH IS-
TALK ABOUT AN ISSUE FIVE. WE'RE
REALLY CONCERNED THAT NOBODY
KNOWS ABOUT THE QUALITY AND THE
OUTCOMES OF THIS DATA. NOR DO WE
KNOW WHAT HOW IT'S ACTUALLY
IMPACTING COMMUNITIES- YOU
PROSECUTE. IT'S ALL GOING TO
PROVISIONING AND EXPANDING THEIR
JOB THEY- WERE NOT YOU'RE
GETTING THE RALEIGH LANDED IN
OUR PLEASE STOP PLEASE OVER THE
THIS PROGRAM THANK YOU. BY
THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT
IT HAS A MENTOR CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE PROSECUTORS
ALLIANCE OF CALIFORNIA AND I
DON'T EIGHT WE SUPPORT VICTIM
SERVICES CONSOLIDATION AND URGE
THE COMMITTEE TO LOOK AT A
COMPREHENSIVE REVIEW OF HOW THE
STATE PROVIDE SERVICES TO
VICTIMS THERE ARE MANY PROBLEMS
IN THE CURRENT SYSTEM THAT
IMPACT COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND
LOW INCOME COMMUNITY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU APPRECIATE- YOUR
REMARKS SHORT THANK YOU NEXT.
FIVE THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I'M SURE MEMBERS MIKE
BELOW FOR THE CALIFORNIA DEFENSE
COUNSEL ALTURAS ALSO AUTHORIZED
TO SPEAK FOR NANCY DRABBLE IN
THE CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIA WE WORKED ON A TRIAL
COURT FUNDING FOR MANY YEARS-
DEEPLY CUT DURING THE RECESSION
AND CLIMBING OUT OF IT IT'S
ESPECIALLY ACUTE BECAUSE OF
COBIT WE SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
A PROPOSAL- ON TRIAL COURT
FUNDING AND WOULD ALSO URGE- AN
INCREASE IN THE AMOUNT DEDICATED
TO PANDEMIC BACKLOG RELIEF.
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT. PINE
THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON BANNEKER DARNELL ON
BEHALF OF THE DEBT FREE JUSTICE
COALITION RESTITUTION GROUP
CALLING ABOUT ISSUE NUMBER EIGHT
WE ALSO SUPPORT CONSOLIDATION OF
A CONSERVATIVE INTO A SINGLE
AGENCY AND SUPPORT THE STATE
MOVING TOWARD POLICIES THAT ARE
MEETING PLEASE ASSEMBLY PART ALL
THAT DOES IS WHICH WE BELIEVE IN
. ENDING UP THAT USING CRIMINAL
FINES FIND COMMON. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT. THE
FINAL REMINDER PRESS ONE ZERO
FOR PUBLIC LINE THIRTY NINE GO A
- I'M SURE CHRIS WAS ON BECAUSE
ADVOCATE WAS A LONG ALREADY
ACTUALLY THE COMMONS MADE OVER.
ON THE SHE- RELIGIOUS ALONGSIDE
. THANK YOU. THANK YOU X.
BALLENGER UP WHY WE SHOULD GOING
TO TELL YOU ELSE IS QUEUED UP WE
HAVE QUEUING UP RIGHT NOW ONE
MORE PLEASE OKAY AND THAT WILL
OUR LAST MONTEREY. OKAY YEP SO
ONE Q. UP. I CAN'T. WE WITH THIS
ONE MOMENT. WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
LINE FORTY YOU ARE OPEN. HI MY
NAME IS TRAGIC MOLLY AND WITH
THE EAST BAY COMMUNITY LAW
CENTER I WANT TO ECHO MY
COLLEAGUES' STATEMENTS ON THE
SOLE ASSESSMENT PROPOSAL AND
REITERATE THE IMPORTANCE OF
ELIMINATING THE ENTIRE THREE
HUNDRED DOLLAR FEE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH- NO
DEPARTMENTS BUT IT UP. THAT'S IT
MR MODERN YES YEAH THAT IS THAT
THANK YOU BACK AND THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR ALL YOU DO YOUR
SERVICE- AND THANK YOU EVERYONE
FOR YOUR PATIENCE THANK YOU TO
MY COLLEAGUES ARCTUR STAFF- FOR.
AND COOPERATION THANK YOU TO ALL
THE INDIVIDUALS WHO DID
PARTICIPATE IN PUBLIC TESTIMONY
TODAY. PLEASE KNOW THAT YOU ARE
VERY VERY IMPORTANT AND WHAT YOU
COMMUNICATE TO US IF YOU WERE
NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY OR IF YOU
WANT TO YOU SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS
OR SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING. TO
THE BUDGET FISCAL REVIEW
COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE.
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
ARE VERY IMPORTANT TO US WE WANT
TO INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS. THANK
YOU AGAIN AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION THE SENATE BUDGET
FISCAL REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE
NUMBER FIVE IS NOW ADJOURNED
THANK YOU.